hello everybody happy
wednesday march
30th
yes it is
everybody's favorite day of the week
except um games
um it's wednesday or i think do people
like i think people don't like
wednesdays
it's not monday
friday's better
[Laughter]
wow one
mom
another master symphony of sounds
thank you thank you very much truly an
artist i think you could if you could
frame those they'd be in the uh they'd
be in the louvre appreciate it right
next to the mona lisa yeah
my life oh today's episode sponsored by
mint mobile thank you
i um
life is suffering
on top of my illness that i'm struggling
to overcome i'm almost out of
antibiotics
and definitely far from 100
last night i got a burrito and i'm
pretty sure it gave me food poisoning
thank you for the for the music
i
like
it's true
and it's just i don't know i'm
discombobulated i'm snotting i'm
from the back side it's just like a jet
pack bro
every time i sit on the bathroom i get a
little lift
it's a nice visual it's just i was
afraid to drive here to be honest i was
putting it off because i was afraid i
was just going to pull over and [ __ ] in
someone's lawn
like that back here
i'm dehydrated
[Music]
life's tough oh my god
[Music]
i just want to be normal again
anyway we do have a lot of juice today
we got the jimmy lee thing which we've
been teasing for a long time and i gotta
warn you guys
those that are sensitive to offensive
language and uh maybe i would say who
are empaths
who are gonna be feeling extra
sorry for some of the people jimmy comes
to
you may want to skip this segment
i'm just i think that's fair i i think
because i'm just a genuine trigger
warning yeah for the jimmy said i mean
i'll let you guys know before we get
into it and we'll get there but i'm just
saying you know
i don't i don't want everyone
complaining about how offensive he is
because i'm telling you now
just saying just skip it if it's too
much for you the man is a is a tornado
of
insults
oh god
it's a non-stop
of it's just non-stop offensiveness and
even if you're not sensitive just have
your having that suit ready for the
cringe
yeah
um we also have a really great store
we're gonna talk about av boxing idubbbz
which we teased in the last episode who
are idubbbz uh david dobrik who's doing
a crypto scam
it's awesome
oh and cav cav came out and published an
article he's still complaining about
wikipedia i love it it's so funny it's
so funny too there's actually a lot of
good stuff too to get to today unlike
most shows yeah
but before we start
a very quick
shout out
to teddy fresh who
this
3 31 what day is that that's tomorrow
thursday
thursday this weekend
we are doing 30
off the entire website
it's a friends and family cell
unfortunately for you guys
you're all friends and family wow
wow
30 off the entire website
if you've been thinking about trying
teddy fresh or if you're
a veteran now is a great time
we don't often do sales
so now's the time to
try the item you had your eyes on
for a little bit of a discount there 30
big discounts
um
got some cool graphics too i want to
show off to you guys
[Music]
friends and family so there you go
tomorrow starting at
10 yeah it's usually 10 a.m pst
does it say that oh yeah at 10 a.m pst
teddy fresh
very exciting so yeah there's a lot
there's a lot of really amazing stuff on
the website right now
so
there you go
all right let's get into the juice shall
we
now what time is jimmy uh he's gonna
call in by the way we're gonna have to
basically debrief we'll have a little
talk yeah we're gonna have a little talk
yeah yeah
uh what time is he calling you uh we
told him around uh three or three thirty
our time we just let him we said we'd
let him know okay good because we we're
going to talk to him after it right we
don't want him during it yeah got it
yeah
okay
you know also there was a lot of
backlash on the will smith uh episode i
made a video on ethan or ethan klein
channel
so i don't want to go into great depth
about it actually i'm just going to
briefly talk about it but
you know a lot of people were mad at me
and the one thing i don't apologize the
one thing i do apologize for
is talking over
the first caller
you know you invite someone on hear him
out that's fine i accept that i i'm
working on listening better so
apologies the first caller i feel like
we got there though you know i settled
down and she she made her point
so i don't know
a lot of y'all just [ __ ] tripping
balls
yeah and just keep [ __ ] my mouth
but that's it that's all i want to say
there was actually
you know
it's funny all this stuff keeps coming
out about it like jada smith there's a
video for just a week ago i didn't know
this being like i love my bald head and
nobody can say anything that bothers me
because i love my bald head
you saw that video
well i saw it but i know it was from a
week ago yeah i didn't know it was a
week ago as well seems like a lot of
comedians uh had the same take as you
yours was actually pretty uh vanilla if
i may say so myself yeah what was some
of those tom sagura tweets were like
nuclear bro [ __ ] wild actually send
me the most nuclear tom cigarette oh
yeah i don't know if you can even
read it on the show to be honest
well yeah i guess you know the problem i
think is that the there is a loud
minority i mean when we did the poll it
was 20 so by no means the
majority but very passionate fortnite
you know the other thing i was thinking
about that i never talked about
oh let me show tom's tweet
i also saw what's that one guy who had
that netflix show he also had a really
good
monologue about it oh not this one but
this was good
thomas
a bunch of insane this week they're sold
out it's gonna be fun i got a big
surprise for you if you come to the show
you don't have to laugh but if you come
on stage i will slap the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of you and the [ __ ] you brought
i mean the thing about tom is um
he always does this when there's like uh
some sensitive issue he always just like
push it
to the extreme for kind of a meme so
i understand people getting offended by
what he's saying but i also know like
i don't know what to say rose come on
you know the the most offensive one
was
let's see this this is right when it
happened this was the most offensive one
and i read this without con without the
without the
and adore i i read this in pure
partialness
no comment
i'm only a vessel for words at this
moment
[ __ ] will smith candy ass smacking to do
four inches shorter and 50 pounds
lighter he's just in his feelings
because his small-headed [ __ ] been
[ __ ] around on him for years and he
takes it
we all know who he wishes he could slap
hashtag [ __ ] will not funny
[ __ ] my wife's no
you gotta include chris rock then going
i'm going to
okay i can have that yeah yeah
yeah and he kept going you know this
this be this [ __ ] been bald
jokes about
it or her are fine it was team af you
sense him about it by a [ __ ] wig i
mean yeah
you know
also there was one uh that i enjoyed
that was
he said
and
the one about his penis being a little
sensitive where is it he didn't erase
anything no i just saw it uh let me see
oh here he goes
lots of sensitive folks in my mansions
i'd like to remind you all to suck my
dick it's a little sensitive too
so obviously tom went in way harder than
anyone
with the express uh intention of
offending people right
yeah but there you have it
but obviously our audience is diverse
and has a lot of opinions and stuff so
that's fine there was one other aspect i
was thinking about that i didn't talk
about
it's like all these women on twitter
fantasizing about a white knight
attacking people on her behalf like
dude you don't even know what you're
wishing for
will smith
is the most class privileged person in
the world the dude went up assaulted
someone in front of millions of people
and then sat down and got a round of
applause i mean
if your man did that he'd be in jail
he'd be paying fines your family would
probably be under a lot of strain i
don't know how long you go to jail for
assault like that you know
lawsuits i'm pretty sure you'd be
wishing it never happened
uh by the time it was all said and done
when your dude's got like a a you know
ankle bracelet on or he's gone from that
he's in jail for a month or something
for some dumb act of
of uh
yeah so i don't know it's [ __ ] stupid
that's it thank you
anything else before we close the case
on that
believe that's it
just saying
just saying
too big of a water swig
are people mad at me you seem you seem
quiet like people are mad at me no let's
just
this this topic i'm so over i gotta be
honest i'm done okay good
not just from you just like
just i opened up twitter this morning
and again my entire feed is just people
arguing back and forth about it it's
like well look what's been said has been
said like everything to be said has been
said at this point
look the last episode we did i got ever
serrated so it's worth mentioning and
and uh
in a brief but there you go okay
oh yes will smith also slapped an
interviewer before that was a weird one
i've seen that the guy gave him like
a hug or a kiss or something
he like backhanded him yeah well dude
kind of did assault him yeah the dude
tried to kiss him on the lips yeah i
mean that one was warranted i found a
little odd how he um
backhand slapped him though it wasn't
hard he was like it was like i don't
know it's just i would never think to
backhand slap someone like that
you know
interesting it's shocking yeah pull it
up
real
i can't jerk off to this yes dan for
real oh my god
if we're going to talk about the video
we might as well show it it's
interesting
you don't want to see will smith slap a
guy in with the back of his hand
what the [ __ ]
he
oh i think he was just giving him one of
the like
it seems like he acted like he was but
then he went for his lips oh that that's
obviously
insane
the the the play
so you he went for the lips so
it's hard to tell because the camera's
in front and all this and that pretty
awesome though you just got a little
backhand oh it's a minute black too
that's a while ago i'll just give you
okay there you have it
history of slapping
dan anything to add
definitely not
dan thoughts
thought stan
i'm gonna come
what would you have done would you have
slapped a man for trying to kiss you on
the lips on the record shove them off me
if somebody's assaulting me yeah
okay there you have it dan everybody dan
good luck
[Applause]
all right let's move on
oh another one other thing i want to say
puff daddy said on stage that the both
chris ruck and will smith are cool that
was a [ __ ] lie chris rock's brother
yeah because by the way and this is a
[ __ ] everyone's like you're more
angry than chris rock i'm like or do you
know that for sure no chris rock is
pissed his brother says it's on
and puff daddy lied about them being
cool for what purpose i don't know but
chris rock is angry and he's coming
damn thoughts
i got no more thoughts on this damn
what's your favorite will smith movie
uh
probably bad boys oh okay one or two
boys or three
i get the first and the second one
confused i don't know the original men
in black is pretty [ __ ] good too
though did he slap anyone in bad boys
oh yeah not larry yeah for sure
i actually i honestly love
i don't know if this is controversial or
not but the first man in black is such a
great movie and i love it so much no i
love that movie
so cool i love the concept yeah i like
willis great in it you know she's great
i like the pursuit of happiness movie
makes me cry yeah that's a good movie a
little depressing yeah i don't like the
depressing films i'm too fragile
sometimes when you need a good cry you
know you just throw that good cry yeah
has anybody seen the one that he starred
in with the sun the like sci-fi movie
i've heard it's like one of the worst
movies ever made i didn't get through it
it was so good yeah i tried it just had
it more of a curiosity i heard it's like
brutally bad i never i've never seen it
well there's like an interesting
backstory too but he did it because he
wanted to like bond with him
sure yeah
but like dude i don't know it's like a
movie about a father and a son right so
you know casper there's a better way of
bothering
than working together yeah i suppose
there you have it guys all right moving
on
oh the girl who whipped cam has
apparently
become uh she's blowing up on instagram
right yeah she's been getting a lot of
love from the football journal i was
like that's weird that she's getting
love i'm used to people being like
on uh
they're on like hospice care or
something after our
you know our fans come
to say our you know sometimes our fans
are kind of a nightmare i think they
only attack us they're nice to other
people for the most part okay well
that's nice to know what's up everybody
i just wanted to leave this video here
because
today has been such a
funny day
if you're here from h3tv
or
cam grants
i just want to say thank you guys for
the overwhelming
oh anyway [ __ ] yeah people were nice
there see
we're not all bad
yay
yay good job
oh yeah and then there's that cursed
image from the vegas trip
i had asked cameron to
do the ai correct all of our faces
and um
fupa troopa had done it it was very time
consuming
so here it is
here we go
oh my god so hear me here i am god
i look like i can't play it it's cursed
i mean it's not a bad attempt i mean it
doesn't look anything like me but uh
yeah
considering what i had to work with
looks kind of like oliver tree
the texture of the face and stuff
love
i mean i would say that that one
looks very believable
to the uh you know the glitched out one
on the left like i don't think his
forehead is that big i don't know what
happened here dude i'm freaking scared
but yeah that's exactly what it looks
like
does that look like sonic
it's so cursed
what happened to your eyes bro your eyes
gave me some crow's feet that went off
my face
damn amy's seen better days man
what the freak sure didn't help that
there's a the face behind all of us
probably right i confused it
you know that one's good i'm honestly
thinking that that one's pretty good no
yeah i think ian and chantal look the
most normal like
i look like a happy little gnome yeah
yeah you got a baby
kind of a baby face but pretty good do
not play this man chantelle looks like
completely normal perfect
like what the hell they nailed that
fantastic she's stunning
that's incredible it's actually and it
looks like her too right yeah no that if
she put that on facebook people wouldn't
even think twice yeah right all right
ela turned into oh god something
someone else
entirely that's that's hildy right there
that is healthy
her evil doppelganger
oh boy
sam's looks like i'm not gonna lie i'm
seeing trisha paytas
but don't worry it's not your real face
i mean it's just
but do you see it
i guess a little bit
guys i think i'm gonna have to take a
trip to the bathroom here for real yeah
i'm holding it i'm i'm squeezing my
cheeks but i'm just warning you
know what's going to be happening here
lena's is not bad but like obviously
pretty weird too yeah what do you think
are her eyes different colors
pretty
i feel like one of her eyes more
masculine
[Music]
yeah i don't know yeah it ended up it
ended up pretty weird
zach
my boy
i don't know you know [ __ ] is going on
other than the eye it was pretty good
not too bad but yeah the eye
the all right
they give you wally p's
i look dead dude
yeah you look like a good dab or you
think i'm gonna look like when i'm like
you know taxidermy or some shade your
hair looks beautiful bro thank you yeah
it had the color is really good right
now and um
yeah well i'm talking about the ai hair
oh yeah
but i appreciate whatever compliment you
just gave me
your hair does look good let me see your
hair yeah let's see it it looks great
see those luscious looks and the a i
knew they knew yeah
oh my god they changed her race
oh my god that turned asian
what happened
interesting though because it looks like
her but asian
interesting
i mean that that's so interesting
oh my god you guys it's bizarre
[Music]
looks like i don't know what happened
his search is
you got the joker thing totally yeah
i feel like i have seen a dude who looks
like this though interestingly
oddly enough everyone feels like they
know someone who looks like dan
i want to be surprised he got one of
those faces on him faces someone said
silly tonka is evolving into zumpa
loompa
[Laughter]
all right guys um
uh i'm shading my pants
[Music]
we're back hey we're back
ethan just sprinted out of the room
uh
let me take a look at some of these
wonderful beautiful member messages that
we got in the meantime i was wanting to
answer one earlier somebody asked about
leftovers
uh
we have talked about a few times but i
don't expect everybody to
watch every episode so i'm pulling up my
calendar right now just to remind myself
so we are scheduled
to record the first leftovers back on
where is it
[Music]
uh
here it is
so we're recording it on
april 28th
and it will be published on may 1st so
there you have it may 1st
the return
assign of the king hassan
we'll be coming back to the studio
um
we got a do an overhaul of the uh
leftover set
oh yeah oh yeah that's gonna be fun i
think we gotta tune it up a little bit
uh put a couple more million into it
yeah just drop another couple millie
yeah
um any leftovers and elden ring updates
um well i just gave you a leftovers
update but the elden ring update is
we're
pretty much all over it at this point i
think yeah i believe dan ethan and a few
others beat it but the rest was kind of
i think maybe just me and ethan or maybe
just anybody else beat it no i was it
was consuming you guys were all so blind
no it was i was at the end but it's just
taking up so much time and i need to
focus on my fight but i can't wait to
get back into it after the fight okay if
i don't die if he doesn't die he's not
gonna die you're gonna [ __ ] win yeah
yeah we'll save all that trash talk when
we talk about it
but it was real nice on friday uh my
opponent released a photo of himself and
as soon as we got to vegas the whole
comment section and the reddit was that
i'm going to die alright
it was a fun way to start the vacation i
gotta say
it's just a photo you know that can you
know the angle
be manipulated a little bit we'll talk
about it more we're we're planning on
talking about the the whole fight on
this episode
stupid piece of [ __ ]
that's another little teaser new sound
bite yeah
keemstar shout out
what the [ __ ] was that the burp from the
governor lady yeah i don't know why
it's [ __ ] crazy
uh let's see what else we got hi dan and
great moves keep it up thanks
hi dan it's my birthday wish me please a
b a b wish ahmed uh a happy birthday
ahmed happy birthday happy birthday more
happy birthday
content court dead no no it's um
you know we just
it's never really been intended to be a
regular thing we we do it when we have
an appropriate target you know and
somebody that we want to uh
do a deep dive on and spend the whole
episode on um there'll be more yeah
look at idubbbz you just contact cobb
like once a year once every three years
yeah exactly so
it'll come back
there was somebody we were recently i
won't say who but we were kind of yeah i
was thinking that too i just don't
recall who it was yeah well there might
be one in the not wendy williams we
wouldn't do that to her girl
would not do that to our girl
uh shout out to cam who has the best
name ever says
cameron bias bias much
uh
i hope hassan doesn't simp for putin on
his return i don't think he will i don't
i'm just taking a stab there uh arby's
meat mountain update um
it hasn't rotten as far as i know right
it's chilling pretty much the same yeah
maybe love uh can do another
update in the near future damn what are
your thoughts on the smiths dude
no comment to be honest whoa whoa whoa
whoa what not a fan
like will smith are you talking about
the band smith oh i assumed the band i
don't
yeah okay that's what i'm maybe they
were trolling me and we're just
meant the the smith family but you don't
like the smiths i've never been a fan
and morsi is just a douche i will agree
with that but i'm shocked i thought you
would like their music i have no idea
who it is
yeah i mean they're kind of in the space
of a lot of bands that i was into
growing up but um they just never did it
for me sorry to dismiss fans i love them
dude
dan why are you so cute when you talk
trash
that's one of the donations no someone
said that the donations but i didn't see
the name was it
possibly he seems like he's a fan why
are you so cute when you talk [ __ ]
uh
did you see shane dawson as having a
baby uh we did and
we did
best of luck to them what can you say
um
uh
y'all are wrong about uh fit and fresh i
mean you don't even know their name
are you aware that coconuts and barbados
was taken completely out of context on
off the rails 24 at 1 58 15. yeah i i
get it he's he was saying he
at that time he when he was growing up
in barbados picked coconuts and he was
using it as a way to reference how young
he was so yes i am aware it's still fun
barbados it's still [ __ ] funny i
don't know what to say
uh
a b plug cedar point oh i [ __ ] love
you
me and lena still got our season passes
even though we haven't lived in michigan
for two years it's this amusement park
in ohio oh yeah and it's like
it's crazy because there's like nothing
in ohio no offense you guys don't have
time there's nothing a michigan either
but cedar point is the best amusement
park like the roller coasters out here
six flags all that does not compare to
cedar point they used to have the
fastest and tallest in the world until i
think ferrari world beat them a couple
years ago
when is the next leftovers okay
how are you just pissed off dan
rewind
about three minutes and you'll get your
answer i'm not going over it again
uh oh
oh dude ethan looks
[Laughter]
you're right buddy
i don't know if i can sit bro it's that
bad can't wipe anymore you know what i
mean
i do know what you mean like the bidet
is in there which is good but it hurts
even from the bidet pressure you know
use the bidet now well for that yeah you
need something around you need some
rosebud dude oh my god
rosebuds yeah no rosebud like the
solving though the stuff that he leaked
all over some dude's seat yeah
like it's like a vaseline you need that
or my [ __ ] yeah
for your [ __ ]
if i squirt this on my anus do you think
i seem to spit it out of my hair
i don't know you should be able to taste
your ass
oh my god resting why is this happening
i mean are you uh
i don't know how to get comfortable it's
just so much pain sam's asking do you
want some tums
your tummy a little bit i need oh i mean
tom's i don't know is that going to help
me clog i need like a stool hardener i
think you need to i don't know if that's
a good idea though because you want to
get it out right
yeah yeah poisoning yeah i guess tom's
is more for like
comics you need a modium that's what you
need
but i need a body transplant
his stomach is upset but it's i think
it's beyond the point where it's still
yeah
i haven't peed like all day because i
just keep
peeing i have no water in my body
it seems like nobody
trails level of dysentery
[Music]
all right let's keep going
let's keep it rolling
i mean if we have to cut it short today
uh you know maybe i'll feel better i
just need a little time for my butthole
to feel for the
relax from the trauma of what just
happened in there yeah i think i just
like my pants it's like
it's like hard pressure okay a good
stream you know what i mean
super soaker what color is it that like
weird reddish brown
it's not red
oh okay if you go again let zach take a
look yeah i'm very interested and
fascinated by this oh it's okay i'll
just
i'm gonna flush twice knowing that he's
trying to look at my [ __ ] god damn it
wow
ian is quick
green screen god
that water is cold too man that the day
water it it surprised you doesn't it a
little bit
yeah you lean forward a little bit like
to make sure it gets yeah if you don't
lean forward it's just like up your ass
correct right
how do you draw your ass
oh tp
but
don't you have hair on your ass
no i trim you trim your ass yeah
[Music]
really yeah what's so weird about that
it's not weird just well like do you use
like a razor yeah i get back there
my clippers you know very carefully like
a beard
beard cutter you got one specifically
for that purpose right
[Laughter]
i've gone pubes to face it's okay to
admit it yeah my my pubes my beard it's
happened my pew beard i'll i'll admit
i'll back you up all right yeah [ __ ]
i've never gone ass to face but it's the
same it's the same trimmer i don't know
that it's worse than pubes to face well
it's not like you know it's kind of it's
not the full [ __ ] it's just like you
know
inner cheeks
the hoover dam you know
what what number do you use like what
how many millimeters uh no guard oh wow
what but doesn't your ass get super
itchy that's what i was about to add
well then you take some rosebud
so you're just walking around with like
vaseline can i can i give can i give my
process here yeah i'd love to hear it
okay so i trim my pubes i trim my ass
okay
then i shower
so that gets rid of any excess like
residue yeah wait you shower every time
you [ __ ]
[ __ ] you taking bro what does this have
to do with [ __ ] okay wait wait wait
wait
sorry i was so you you shower before you
shave or after i shower after okay so
that way it clears everything out
and then after the shower i put like
some rosebud or some vaseline or
aquaphor or something make sure it's all
good you know i get my balls and all
that [ __ ]
so you vaseline your balls yeah dude but
now how how often do you do it because
i don't think one application would be
enough
application of what of the rosebud
okay how much rosebud do i put like how
how frequently on a daily basis do you
apply that i only want to trim my ass
and [ __ ] only one trim
pubes so i trim my pubes i don't know
every
once every two months
once every few months well yeah
just look into
laser hair removal
nah i i don't think that stuff's as
effective as people think no i enjoy you
know manscaping it's an interesting
process and it's almost like fearful in
a way because like oh am i gonna clip
myself you know
gives you like the thrill yeah i do so
do do you sorry if this is there's a
graphic no i always have when i'm
manscaping i have trouble around the
shaft i'm so scared right um
the delicate procedure for sure was i
nick i feel like every time i do it no
matter how hard i nick the shaft there's
always a little blood time yeah i don't
know why i try my best not a few times
over the years the thing is the guard on
the
razor
doesn't
it doesn't get close enough you have to
take it off right and i don't know
what's going on there but i just keep
nicking myself why are you using a guard
i say take the guard off
do you use a guard to trim your pubes
though yeah
why
because i don't want it like to my skin
it's too short
that's fair ela doesn't know to be fair
eli doesn't like it she likes it to be a
little
like a one or two you know what i mean
maybe i'll start using a guard i usually
just go but for the shaft you don't want
to guard no no no that's like meticulous
like
small paintbrush type [ __ ] you know
um
but do you grab your your hog and like
you know
i guess more like a piglet i guess
here grab your let's say this is your
hog right
yeah
you take it and pull it to the side so
it's all like your your thigh
and you just yeah that's one way to do
it so yeah okay yeah but that's fine but
i'm just saying the shaft gives me
difficulties
that's you know sometimes what i do ian
if you can switch to me is i like to go
more of like
get this chapstick this is too far
yeah what i like to do is uh
you know
is take a
take it and you push it to the side
[Laughter]
but
yeah um to close this story i i shaved
my ass so
okay you guys ever hear those like balls
of wax i don't know if it's just a thing
that like middle eastern girls use or in
my experience or i have seen them you
know what i'm talking about okay so i
guess it's more it's a ball of wax
well i didn't know i did because they
saw the ones that i've seen in the past
like it's from the arabic store so i
don't know but my ex thought it was
funny to roll it up and slap it on my
ass before oh that was the most painful
[ __ ] it's for like removing hair yeah
that was a [ __ ] nightmare
does lena ever like help you groom maybe
uh not to brag
but i don't have that much hair
i think
yeah
twink king
no but no ela does not i don't want to
involve elo my grooming that's not
a good crossover
didn't ask what about you
i'm
not going to respond to that you asked
the [ __ ] question
i asked a b i didn't ask you
what's the difference you asking
questions you better bounce them around
answer them
okay yes chantal's helped me in the past
yeah okay
sugar wax by the way that's what that's
called
you know there's some areas i can get
butthole
she shaved your butthole
maybe
well
it's true love it's a keeper right there
yeah like seriously
[Laughter]
are you guys doing stuff back there
i just find it it's easier to not that
there's any problem with it i'm not you
know a rim job is a beautiful thing
never i'm not not ronnie mundo over here
okay nothing to be ashamed of zach no i
just i i find it easier to wipe when you
have no hair on your eye i guess so
because i have a problem with the bidet
it's cleaner it's easier to shower
it's a good time man
all right
nice little tangent there
as much as i'd love to put a buffer
topic between
uh it is time for ads
we only have one ad so let's just thank
them real fast that's been mobile of
course who we love
we love it mobile don't we folks
if saving more and spending less is one
of your top goals for 2022 why are you
still paying insane amounts of money
every month for wireless
switching to mint mobile is the easiest
way to save this year as the first
company to sell premium wireless service
online only mint mobile lets you
maximize your savings with plans
starting at just
month
what do you think dad
uh yeah it's a great service i switched
to it from one of the big boys you know
who i'm talking about let's say their
name here scammers yeah fraudsters rods
all of them
but yeah uh memmobile uses the same
technology same uh you know networking
backbone as the big people at a fraction
of the price there's really no downside
so you're using the mobile you love it
it's just the same thing but cheaper
that's right
that sounds like a good deal
so for anyone looking to save extra
cash this year mobile offers premium
wireless for just 15 bucks a month by
going online only and eliminating the
traditional cost of retail mint mobile
passes
significant savings on to you all plans
come with unlimited talk and text plus
high speed data delivered on the
nation's largest 5g network use your own
phone with any mobile plan and keep the
same phone number along with all your
existing contacts and with mobile choose
the amount of monthly data that's right
for you and stop paying for data you
never use switch to mint mobile get
premium wireless service starting at
just 15 bucks a month to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
i get the plans shipped to your door for
free
go to mintmobile.com h3 that's mint
mobile dot com h3 cut your wireless bill
to 15 bucks a month at midmobile.com
thank you
[Music]
feeling nauseous now oh
jesus if i start puking we'll call it a
day
okay what kind of what kind of burrito
did you have it just was a normal
burrito it's just a chicken or steak
chicken
and it seemed it tasted fine it looked
fine
well undercooked maybe
hopefully you know it's a salmonella
kind of thing
undercooked maybe i don't know
chicken will [ __ ] you up
it was little chunks so it's hard to
tell but right
it wasn't a chipotle burrito okay
yeah
i'll tell you what it was there's this
little taco shop we order because
they're open until like 2 a.m so
sometimes when we're hungry awesome
we order from them but
this is a late night burrito a late
night street breed
um yeah let's get you
all right let's let's get to jimmy lee
the man is waiting for his time in the
sun
so once again
guys with peace and love this is a
warning
if you are easily offended or have
triggers or you're an empath or whatever
it is
i guarantee there's something in this
video that's going to offend you
so skip the next 30 minutes or something
if you come back and you see jimmy's
face just wait go away again and come
back you don't see jimmy's face anymore
okay
oh
this video is going to put me over the
top dude
[Laughter]
oh no
all right guys here we go i i uh you
want to say anything before we play this
sack
uh you apologize
no because i didn't do anything wrong i
was i was we were filming a documentary
and we were don't you know don't shoot
me i'm just the piano player
um
we we went out there and we we tried to
film jimmy like like like a mazel's
documentary
um and this is what we got
this is yeah i want to say that we do
not condone or doris not at all not nor
did we participate nope we were any of
the shenanigans we were simply there to
observe correct an animal in its natural
habitat in fact at times you guys were
even trying to pull them back and be
like dude you gotta you gotta chill we
pulled him back and told him this is too
far you can't do this and he was he does
this stuff anyway so we didn't we didn't
even right he was coming to l.a yeah
right yeah uh to do this don't don't
blame us right and we're like well i am
washing my hands with peace and love he
like
he was here for a vacation all
disclaimers
are being made with peace and love this
is jimmy lee the jersey outlaw
let's make it happen
[Music]
so we are here with the legend the man
the myth mr jimmy lee the jersey outlaw
he's very graciously treating us to it
very nicely this guy's paying over here
i didn't tell him yet
now i just want i'm gonna have to pause
because it's long that magazine that
magazine he brought to the podcast like
two years ago when we had him on right
you're right play magazine yes
which he only texts me about like five
times every month so the magazine yeah
what does he say about it he's like
check this out he already but we already
showed it he doesn't he doesn't remember
he
sends the same things to zach like every
day
all right it's a lot let's go
he's getting the bill you've got a lot
of money i know when your wife dies
you're gonna be all right
good to see you back at men's clothes
anyways we're having a nice breakfast
was that guy angry he said i got a lot
more money yeah he was not happy about
that nice to see you back in men's
clothes
you're gonna notice a lot of kind of
ancient homophobia transphobia and stuff
like that
so trigger warnings usually
yeah you usually jimmy still they have a
timeline today to go to certain areas
and interact with people do street
comedy the idea is to end up in the
hospital at the end of the day right and
when i'm in the hospital cam and i keep
them in stitches it's going to make me
look a lot better than i look now from a
9 to a 10.
that was polite and that was very about
from a one to a three
one thing cameron did they say about
joel that he knows how to listen
nobody knows he's got nothing to say
he's making me look pretty though hey
what's going on here getting the makeup
done yeah a little powder a little paint
makes me what i ain't are you having a
penile enlargement put in yeah i got
that last week but my wife rejected it i
just make him fabulous by the way this
is my favorite part when he's
self-deprecating he's charming he's
funny
this is my note for jimmy when we bring
him on because when he gets out there
and he
turns it on other people it just goes
really really south fast yeah
uh cameron you want to
eat something i won't say nothing need a
cookie i won't i won't tell my body what
do you weigh
oh you think it looks skinny i
appreciate it
you know anorexia you're you're pretty
lean too i'm a lean god but that's
because the asian chicks like guys lean
i got what they call yellow fever you
know yellow fevers young bring them in
stiletto heels but be sure to bring them
but bring them asian never caucasian
young not the university bring them
young
bring them young
and by the way i mean his makeup artist
is asian i think right
add extra layers of cringe right right
right bring them young baby break them
young are we even a minute in i'm
already yeah i made a 40.
but be sure to bring them i'd like that
i don't think you guys did though guess
what now we got to do this part you
think the makeup was hard
so the hair light now you got the
hairline situation you guys talked a lot
about right um
[Music]
yeah
like you'll see once trying to lower it
quite a bit i mean it
god love the guy it looks like he's like
in a mortician makeup chair like
actually
like it has to kind of be it's really
see how high up it is it's got to kind
of be like tonight
could we get ethan and do his hair like
this like a full inch down
yeah i think it's looking really sharp
oh my god
i look like i did 20 years ago zach
i'm ready i'm ready you guys ready well
i want to be like you you look like
trick or treat charlotte you want to be
like me change your clothes you got
clothes for me yeah i got clothes are
you right about making snapchat i got
some place to be
let's trick or treat charlie we still
can't figure that out okay because
there's a lot to decode in here that's
kind of hard but okay trick-or-treat
charlie
maybe someone in the chat knows what
that means
i'll keep an eye out
perfect
because the jersey outlaw and the mini
jersey outlaw are getting ready to shoot
in hollywood california here
we
go so did jimmy just tell you you're not
allowed in the shot i'm not allowed
i just got [ __ ] over
it's hard to shoot i have a i have an
idea do the shot in front of the limo i
wish security would fix his collar
though
yeah can i can i just do one thing i
mean no offense to this can i fix your
caller
oh
right there yeah he's kind of right i'm
sorry there was a big issue with the
caller and you were got a little
sensitive about the thinking he was mad
at you too zach what happened here his
collar looked like [ __ ] and we were
filming and we we couldn't have that so
okay little is that presumptuous to fix
a man's collar or i he i didn't touch
him
you didn't you just pointed it out i
don't think what you did was out of line
i don't think he was in any way i don't
know i didn't see any signs he was
actually angry he definitely was he was
really i mean this dude was like ex
israeli forces and like
he was not happy he was really the
caller issue really got him yeah i mean
where did jimmy find these guys these
actually guys are actually like scary
ass bodyguards there's some company he
hires and like elite ex-military yeah
like something but yeah that really
pissed him off but we're bros now we're
homies okay that's good oh wow somebody
said uh jimmy's got austin from ace
family's hairline when they painted on
the doctor dot she's slower yeah
that's right i mean austin has two
hairlines though
right well jimmy how did it do with that
that's true actually with the paint yes
so come here all right so one
two three go
he just
just squeezed the [ __ ] out of my hand
when i told him to fix his collar
he didn't like that i told you we're
gonna get killed by the end of the day
your teeth look like the spice girls are
all different colors and they're all
doing their own thing
that's funny did we film that that was
actually a good one the right lights on
the red light saw that's what they said
at the place last thought i had to leave
200 when i left you know we're going to
beverly hills where the prostitution
joke yeah got it
so that that one he says a lot about the
spice girl's teeth thing i noticed
meet the famous which would be the
little baby reference
yeah that's my squirrel's joke
yeah a little probably a more up-to-date
reference you can make that i mean spice
girls is you know
timeless zacharoony i feel like i pissed
him off and i just want to apologize can
i shake your hand i'm sorry these guys
are good guys don't worry about it okay
i know where you stay we have to come up
with a stage name for you so we could
call him the zacker
so people remember it said you want to
be known as the zacker i go by zilli
zonka now i don't like that
[Applause]
okay so this is like
you guys managed to get all these people
there to wait and think there's like a
real celeb coming out
uh i i guess you guys are down at like
uh
rodeo yeah rodeo yeah
and then jimmy comes out talking about
the audio it's my this is my favorite
part
like look at this shot it's so perfect
they're waiting for the celeb
it's happening
hold it i want to check audio audio or
you have my audio where is he you have
audio
all right i want you guys to meet my
gate my gay friend zach
zach
took him on a vacation
and everybody came where you from
english how come you don't eat the
muffins listen
your teeth look a little bit like the
spice girls they're all different colors
and they're doing their own thing there
are people in london called dentists
that is okay
so can i i'm his protege this is my
protege so were these jokes funny did
you like these jokes no they're wrong
the first few were okay all right
grandpa time to get you back to life
that's a nice guy
it's a penis you give a cookie goes away
a little less starch on the collar okay
so how you doing here he is
mr magoo how are you doing prowling
how you doing buddy where you from
take off your glasses on you're making a
spectacle yourself
look at this
know you one two three it's gonna get
nuts
one two three beverly hills california
one two great he's a funny guy he's a
funny guy doubled up with two guys no
well we we share everything we do tell
us that that seems kind of inappropriate
i mean john john you know john you're
very popular in hotels
respectively go to my hotel check in or
say john well i went eight years to a
two-year community college wow you stay
out of gay bars i'll stay in them okay
all right now get out
well wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute what do you say stay out of gay
bars and i'll stay in them
yeah yeah
you stayed at gay bars
i'll stay in them a lot of homophobic
like
okay jimmy jokes i guess the only way to
describe it okay interesting i had it up
to here with you yeah i met you in the
little league i know who you are it's a
nice outfit you look like
trick-or-treat charlie for christ's sake
he already said that
he kept i don't know what triggered she
tried guessing it's a charlie brown
reference when i put that into google
and i saw some people in the chat saying
that but i don't know but i know it's
true like i get but like what's the
reference you can't just call everyone
trick or treat charlie
is it from the great pumpkin
i'm guessing charlie brown special so
she's saying you look like a peanuts
person dressed up you look like a kid
you look like you look like a peanuts
dressed up for halloween which i just he
said that joke 20 times like if not more
interesting where are you from
it's your humble county here humble this
jesus jimmy what's your name what's your
name
i ran out of jokes i love that he just
bails i ran out of jokes look who's here
mussolini come on over mussolini here he
is the war is over you lost i don't even
know what to do
you're british you look british with the
teeth no i'm mexican you're mexican yeah
[Music]
don't take anything from oh my god jesus
is so adequate not even a joke yeah
that's just
that's bad
it's a christmas miracle he didn't get
clocked well those security guards are
pretty intimidating to be honest he's
probably
learned that lesson already i think he
hires those guys we hired security
guards for events and stuff and and our
building and all that they don't look
like these guys he went to some like
real elite bodyguard [ __ ] yeah those
guys are like six five they're massive
yeah they were big dudes
you could work a goddamn zoo you can
work at the zoo okay so okay by the way
that's trevor
we've met trevor yes
so i got a question
wait that's the driver he keeps roasting
yeah or trevor he was he was being a
sport to jimmy um and like he was
actually a really nice guy yeah no he
looks like a great sport yeah but he
jimmy just kept letting him a break man
he can't even escape from you no
you're never scared you're gonna get
clocked i got uh oh no yeah but if that
guy swings like my guys are here you
want to try it
i would that guy's pretty funny dude
he really [ __ ] hated me dude yo you
look small next to him
like how tall was it big dude
we were i mean he was maybe an inch
taller than me
um but
i mean the the funny part is like him
and i were sitting next to
each other in the limo and i was sitting
on the hump the whole [ __ ] ride and
i'm just like squished the hump like the
middle yeah yeah yeah
i don't know why up close and personal
pretty much
hey look who's here and look who's here
i heard of the spice girls you girls
look like the bland girls you look like
amy winehouse if she went to rehab
and you you're looking as beautiful
and girls two fives do make a 10.
okay
you look wonderful thank you so do you
you keep this up hon you're gonna have a
massive one by friday
yeah that that one was just like so out
of control
and we blurred their face because
well
without verifying
some age
i don't want to put any uh youngsters on
blast but there was actually one moment
we cut
okay and like i tried to leave in as
much [ __ ] as i could but some [ __ ]
actually had to cut
because it was like i think it was
probably a crime actually without a
doubt
i probably shouldn't even say it right
no no let's yeah
just let him let it lie
trick-or-treat charlie is a minor
character in trick or treat yeah it's a
super chatter uh pointing this out uh i
still don't necessarily get it
well let's ask jimmy when he comes out i
guess we can ask jamie yeah let's trick
or treat charlie if you have any other
jokes you want to ask him let's let's
keep italian yeah that's a good point
we can get to the bottom of a lot of
these
yeah but we need to really get explain
to jimmy that this is i've tried before
like you can't just
go up to a girl and call her ugly i mean
that's not really
a joke a little more premise
right
here's the premise you're ugly
zack you're uh you're getting iced out
by jimmy hardcore man
[ __ ] hardcore the girl is he [ __ ]
roasted they're like they're like who is
that i don't know but he looks famous
pull out his camera
sort of famous give me the lights
yeah i'm talking please the money is
going
will you wait a minute
painting me as i'm trying to do my jimmy
can you teach zach his kids yeah teach
me like so he's a little more i haven't
done it once work with me we're going to
try it right now follow me turn around
zach and do your stick do your do your
catchphrase work with me let's try it
again
i got two kids in private school they
won't tell me where the hell it's at
work with me
take care
all right
get the hell out of that court two hot
chicks two hot mamas
two milfs
two milfs married
pull over
pull over
this was incredible he actually here got
one of these hollywood buses he's famous
just straight up pull over cleared the
[ __ ] bus out pretty incredible out of
the bus let's go everybody out
everybody out let's go we're gonna we're
doing comedy tv everybody out let's go
everybody out
everybody let's go power of confidence
grandfather jimmy lee we take them out
here every tuesday yeah this must have
been so surreal for these people on the
bus just what the [ __ ] is happening
right now these people on vacation la
they just want to do a little tour of
hollywood pull over
jimmy lee's screaming at them to pull
over
then they do
god knows what ensued apologize zz top
is here guys what song are we doing tush
[Music]
if you're having a good time let me hear
you say yay
[Music]
how you doing to my black friend the war
is over everything's good jump run wait
what does that mean to my black friend
the war is over it's over
go on run
i don't a civil war i'm gonna write that
one down too yeah i'll write it wait is
he talking about the civil war god
honestly his jokes are such like deep
racism like
you just don't know where the foot like
a civil war joke
i guess
please
it's uh hold on because that that
actually i was trying to figure out what
that meant now i think i think it must
be that thank you chanel come on chanel
i mean we need a [ __ ] break
where it's just i don't know what's
going on right now how you doing they're
my black friend the war is over
everything's good jump running i could
have been in the olympics i didn't want
to i didn't want to run
i could have been black and been in the
olympics i didn't want to i didn't want
to run i think
what i think that's like a gesture
owens yeah yeah what's the joke it's
like not even a joke it's just like an
obscure reference to a runner
who participated in the olympics during
world war ii or prior to world war ii
owens but why does he say it could have
been black
because maybe he runs i don't know i
don't know
it's it's jimmy man like that's the only
explanation
i gotta say i don't know i'm not reading
the comments actually
i can only imagine but
look he's a one of a kind guy that's for
sure and he's [ __ ] in i mean look at
you never met anyone like this in your
whole life right
that's what it's all about no this is
the only one i have
ptsd
uh
he's the only one on the earth is jimmy
lee amen i can write a joke i've been
doing it and the thing is like he's been
our lives for so long at this point and
he keeps coming back because he's so
persistent
like the first collab i did with him
was god god knows 10 years ago or some
or maybe not seven years ago yeah and
he's just so persistent there we go okay
you know maybe maybe the world's ready
for another jimmy lee cameo it's been
three years
so we can tolerate him once every three
years
lyle that's a really good shot good
that's a good shot okay
table 19 your
breakfast is ready how long have you eat
this do you end up in the emergency room
[Laughter]
table 37 leave
got my eye on you oh this is the best
this is the
the standout moment for sure fun got my
eye on you
how you doing your hairline's worse than
mine this is so inappropriate
it's just so wild i mean they're stunned
they're just they're they're floored
the the poor the poor lady i think
they're they're just like did he really
just got my eye on you got my eye on you
how you doing good your hairline's worse
than mine
and the way he just brushes past them
too after he drops that it's pretty
incredible
holy [ __ ] bro oh
[Laughter]
what's your name a jewish kid lawyer
countless doctor auto parts auto parts
yeah
i've seen better bodies on used car lots
to be honest this is my great job zach
zach wants to say something to you
jack's hair
again he comes back
by the way first one that wasn't enough
he really comes back
but shout out the guy was ready
to be honest this is my father zach zach
wants to say something to you jack's
hair i know you said i told him that
earlier i got my eye on her yeah
legend actually will smith take note
that's how you defend your your lady or
mom or whoever that i don't know if it's
his mom or his lady
and keep it off good call
love him dude that
that to me was
truly left me speechless but there it is
jimmy lee unfiltered baby raw
yeah i dare you to come at him these
bodyguards were beat up your one-eyed
mom there
jimmy we can't go in there
walk with me zack you didn't say nothing
i was like supposed to say that
like you don't want to endorse the jokes
he's saying plus yeah i just we're
observing
you know
so far uh do you feel like jimmy has
kind of
dumped you a little bit completely how
does that make you feel awful i feel
hurt i wanted to come learn but i guess
i am learning i see some people
defending the uh i joke
the i joke was objectively funny some
are saying
so there you have it
i mean at least you can fall like
it it's extremely offensive and rude
thing to say but at least it's like
there's a direct line and it's an actual
joke what yeah right yeah it was cool
like hey you ugly hat alright it was it
was quick thinking of jimmy yeah it was
pretty good we didn't have to google it
right we have to google it to understand
[Music]
what have you learned so far
a [ __ ] catchphrase that's what i've
learned before so far work with me can
we film please
are we filming are we just talking what
are we doing here the policeman's here
maybe you could teach tell zach teach
him a joke yeah
yeah yeah what you want to do is you
want to go to a woman and you want to
say i asked
you if you had mutual orgasm but you
told me you had state farm
i don't get that one
hold on i didn't get that either how you
doing
you remember what i'm here
you're gonna he gave you a joke here's a
future orgasm but you told me you had
state farm teach them a joke yeah
excellent yes jack what you want to do
is you want to go to a woman and you
want to say i ask
you if you had mutual orgasm but you
told
me you had state farm do you have mutual
orgasms okay like mutual it's like it's
an insurance insurance company mutual
orgasms or is it just called
the insurance company is not called
mutual orgasm wait what's the name of
the it's just mutual so and then he's
just it's another insurance company it's
not a great joke because i wouldn't miss
here
no there's nothing like
quick about it there's nothing
i i just maybe i don't understand it i
don't get it it's not funny
okay
well we could take a poll
somebody said like mutual omaha oh
mutual omaha so
mutual orgasm right so that's a regional
thing yeah that a really nice mutual
your insurance jokes are pretty dope you
gotta give them up like i don't think
anyone so yeah it's probably a play on
that but i i've never heard of here's
the thing guys there's no working
comedian today who's doing insurance
jokes
so put a little respect on his name
i don't get the one
tuna and if you feel bad for jimmy first
of all
i love jimmy as a person you need to
worry about that
i'm just saying because sometimes people
are going too hard on poor jimmy
i mean someone made a video for christ's
sake about how i was mean to poor jimmy
yeah that person we've always had this
relationship
and he keeps writing me every day me and
zach 100 times we get it it's fun you
know this is the relationship that we
have
yes and um
it's all love baby it is all love but i
mean to an extent because hey i'm not i
don't want to be involved in honor you
guys keep your
hey i got nothing to do with no i got to
know nothing about nobody
you know what i'm saying
any crimes committed on the set of the
filming i ain't got nothing to do with
join
you remember when i met you now you're
going to be on the bottom
i'm going to be on the top i'll tell you
what we'll do zach's going to get us a
bunk bed
we're doing comedy tv not real well
and uh what are you just hanging out by
yourself i work close by oh i say you
deal with rich people are they painting
the answers most of them and you got to
smile you got to skin underneath because
they pay you and sometimes you want to
just walk but you you bite your lips
you like pancakes french toast french
toast i had it last night my tongue got
caught in the toaster do me a favor take
my wife please okay wait he can't be
doing the take my wife bit
well that toaster joke we were debating
about like
that's obviously a like
vagina licking joke right
hmm
he said his tongue got stuck in the
toaster he's zac saying didn't know if
that was a vagina joke or not
yeah cause i was lost on that too i mean
i guess a vagina joke yeah
the vagina's a toaster apparently yeah
i mean how do you use your tongue stuck
in the toaster yeah
uh aaron just donated 50 bucks that
jimmy is the norm mcdonald of our time
we won't appreciate his jokes till he's
gone
i think he's aiming more for don rickles
just yeah oh don rickles is yeah that's
that's really an inspiration
he's like don rickles but he's like don
pickles
dumb pickles
and yeah
they were saying like french kissing
like french toast that you would make
you know
his jokes are so complicated you have to
really get go to the math board they're
old schools i love them they're like so
french toast french kiss yeah he french
tells french okay
i'm a funny guy i like that thank you
chat we're like crowdsourcing the
interpretation
dude
so uh
i think i have to explain every joke you
look like truman capote in heat take the
hat off
jesus take the hat off will you that was
rude or complimentary
it was rude go
what
like you're just being you're just being
mad at him
that was a great exchange hold on hold
on i gotta watch that again
take the hat off for you jesus christ
lady i'm not sure if that was rude or
compliment it was terrible
it was rude go
what the [ __ ] dude
what on earth why are you angry at them
now
jeez get the [ __ ] out of my face lady it
was rude
come on
someone in the chat said this is like
michael scott trying to be don rickles
oh okay that's good yeah that that helps
me understand what's going on here
a little bit
yeah this is peppy
your teeth look like the spice girls
they're all going in different
directions
how many times does he use the spice
girl's joke today
countless
it's actually not that good of a joke
because teeth generally are one color
right i mean for the most part well that
time he said they're all going different
directions he says they're different
colors and they all go different
directions okay right
does it mean i guess if you have rotted
teeth
yeah it's a little it's not that good to
say 20 times though okay
or just a rich iranian guy that is
hanging out who's watching the limo i
think we parked in a red
jimmy lee and zach
from h3o poor guy's checking his limo
door behind jimmy you see that there
who did that jimmy no i was the uh
[Music]
jimmy lee and zach
from h3h3 this has absolutely got to be
the absolute worst food but they beg
they beg they call me constantly to come
in so we're going to go in you got me in
for tomorrow i think the peninsula
called they put me in around one o'clock
we're on kimmel tonight by the way oh
okay yeah yeah uh one second guys you
have nice scene we'll be in the more i'm
just gonna hit the bathroom quick he was
confirming his reservation for tomorrow
night that's what he was doing so he so
he drove us to this restaurant said get
the cameras roll the cameras right went
in took a took a piss yeah
and now we're leaving
yeah
this was very odd
he drove you guys to a restaurant that
confirmed the reservation right did he
try to get a table maybe for lunch and
they said we don't have one available no
he wanted to film
in the ivy because
he he feels the ivy is like the place to
be for him like that's the end-all
be-all that's the hollywood l.a
restaurant so he wanted to film people
there right they're like no right so he
he wanted to frame it like we just ate
there
because that's like like a david blaine
kind of thing
sure yeah or like he wants to be like oh
i'm jimmy lee i'm famous i eat at the
ivy yeah even pulled the jimmy uh kimmel
card on him but he he did that but all
in reality he just went to go take a
piss which um
we heard which was pretty funny
um you heard him pee yeah cause he's
wrong stream or weak stream
uh it was it was
his prostate might need a yeah
i don't know i get it that happens with
old age yeah
okay shut up we had a great meal oh jack
so he's pretending like they ate there
fantastic
i dropped my pants you dropped the price
it was a rough night all right there's
nobody lower than this girl here not
even you
how's the food guys good i want to say
something
what actually happened
so
he's kicking him out now right because
they said don't film here now is jimmy
sort of bringing us along in his
reality that he is creating himself yeah
like the guy who staged the ellen thing
it's
he's actively getting yelled at behind
you as we speak
we're gonna go before austin picks us up
and throws us out it's hot diggity dog
time with h3h3
and the jersey outlaw work with us work
with me we're gonna get kicked out of
here before we get to eat
pink's hot dogs the worst hot dogs in
l.a and we get stuck here with this guy
the worst place dee what are you doing
i just that seems so like mean to be
saying that in front of the restaurant
i've never eaten there by the way how
are the hot dogs
pretty bad oh you guys didn't even like
it i thought they were good i mean i
haven't been there maybe he was telling
the truth i've been going there for
years
because people there's like huge lines
so you think that's the famous thing
special what's going on
good
but i haven't had in years so i don't
know maybe they've stepped it up a
little bit
it was really bad it's not the kind of
place that steps it up you know whatever
cam said it was really bad yeah i don't
know i said it's really bad love didn't
like it
even love didn't like it no god i think
i got out of the bathroom again you guys
got it trevor
god damn it right over here say hello to
trevor how are you good
he's a black guy you can talk to him
he's not going to do anything
look at the respect they put on those
dogs for him after [ __ ] talking their
establishment damn
they they asked me to say that jimmy uh
zach's
zach's feelings might be a little hurt
because he feels like he's not are you
being shunned no i'll get put you away
you guys no i'm not i'm just getting
dude that's so much that's too much
for jimmy no i don't want to [ __ ] i
do see the resemblance though that being
said
man we'll get you work with me we'll get
you in how long you guys been going like
five hours yeah look we'll get you in
there i gotta i gotta go to the bathroom
this is just this is so [ __ ] up
you guys god damn it
i'm gonna try maybe if i just sit up and
sit on it i like bingo bingo
you can do it try bingo no bingo
bingo yeah you like you sound like al
pacino bingo
bingo
no no no no
try
bingo
get ready to go on jimmy kim by the way
i like the way you said it first zach to
be honest i think you've kind of hit the
post there a little bit you were in the
uh pocket with that one i appreciate
that and this is the point
where i was starting to get really mad
why
i was just done
i was done for this how many hours into
the day was this with jimmy [ __ ] ian
what was this five
yeah yeah probably
he wanted to do 10 hours is that right
he something like that he after where
we're about to go he wanted to go to
like venice and then another place and
he had the limo like all day and all
night and i'm like dude i i can't do
this and ian kept
he was being a really good producer
of the segment
because he kept pushing me and pushing
me and pushing me yes he ends uh
invisible hand there pushing trying to
push things into it yeah it's making
sense a little bit
at the at the start he showed us his
itinerary which i believe was 9am to 7pm
all over los angeles and about 90
minutes in we were getting pretty tired
yeah that's a lot but ian's like but
this this guy who's in a 70 has more has
so much stamina what is going on with
jimmy because he he loves the idea of
like him being famous
doing this to people like he loves it
he's obsessed with it
that limo ride didn't look very
comfortable zach i gotta go
it was awful you guys looked a little
stuck
i'll be back
please no
you know the thing is i i know he looks
up to don rickles but if i give jimmy
some advice first of all don rickles was
what 60 years ago yeah i mean that it's
yeah
also when people would go into don's
show they knew what they were getting
into these are just people on the
streets they didn't sign up for this
show right that's a huge difference
rickles would be in the copacabana and
you're right you'd be expected to be
roasted yeah jimmy's just like some
[ __ ] stranger that's walking up to
you hey you're ugly right you know
which i saw him do which is just like
wait just straight up like hey what's up
you're ugly yeah it was it was a quick
one i don't even know if we got it on
film kind of like the the eye patch uh
pretty much you just like hey you're
ugly yeah
when i was watching you guys at the
restaurant reminds me of the old h3
video because like once he's on a roll
there's no stopping him he's just
bouncing person to person and he's gotta
let him do his thing it's like uh when
he wave when he goes from james to jimmy
lee it's uh
it's dr jekyll and mr hyde yeah
well i gotta say zach you handled
yourself well i would that's this is the
first thing i've ever missed out on i
think shoot wise because i would have
had a panic attack you're lucky so i
commend you and a lot of behind the
scenes
you know we didn't show it but zach was
good and everyone but especially zach
was calming down the crowd and uh doing
damage control so i was getting
frustrated good job thank you i
appreciate that but i was just getting i
was at my point of just like
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
somebody said the uh the spice girls
joke that he kept uh saying was stolen
word for word from nicki glazer at the
roast of rob lowe
oops a little uh jimmy mancia over here
huh
[Laughter]
you know i gotta say though i i would
guess jimmy has the most original
content for the most part original
because you don't understand it right
you know it's it's
there's something to be said of the uh
just being able to
have a rolodex of that many one-liners i
guess i mean i know that they're all bad
but like i couldn't
right yeah just like
he's just on cue
his people
yeah i mean he's quick
he's got that but give him that he's
quick but is it funny well it's the
right a different story
there were you know some extreme times
and
i we just we don't condone that we don't
condone the
the severe
[ __ ] how how did you feel ian behind the
camera was it were you any more
comfortable
you know zach was in front of it with
him i don't know how are you feeling
oh i was super comfortable
[Laughter]
no no it was very painful uh the whole
day but uh you know zach was being such
a good sport yeah and it was nice to
[Laughter]
we all kind of got to commiserate
as it was happening you know we'd go off
in little group and be like what the
[ __ ] just happened but then
love could hear jimmy on the mic
because jimmy was miked up so as we'd be
talking like this is we got to get out
of here man we're all tired this is
ridiculous and then love will be like i
hear jimmy he's saying that he thinks
that we're all mad at him and
i know it was it was tough
yeah
it's a weird situation with him because
i don't know i don't know
i don't even know how to explain it but
you kind of want to feel bad for him but
then he just
takes him not long to
be like okay never mind it's hard to
feel bad for him what's that what are
you saying what's that quote like once
that come out they always try to bring
me back in
what is that from godfather three yeah
one of the three movies that you quote
endlessly probably third one not so much
i guess yeah
less so the third one one moment that we
we didn't get on camera we weren't
recording but uh jimmy pissed off some
guy on a bike
and then
uh
we j the guy was like if you're gonna
put me in your video i want some cash
oh yeah and then
jimmy didn't want to do that he's like
get in the limo get in the limit we got
in the limo we drove like
15 minutes away
and then
in a couple minutes later he's telling
his jokes and this guy rolls up on the
bike jimmy goes
oh no not this guy and the guy's like
come on followed us and jimmy tossed him
like 20 bucks he's like all right let's
get out of here wow you [ __ ] yeah i
think ethan's right he must have got
that security guard after having a like
an actual experience oh yeah because
jimmy in in some of his other videos
he'll go out
and he'll go with what he calls the
his terms bandito girls
and it's these two girls that he goes
around with and you know
less intimidating i guess right
um
but cam
cam gets saying he's like thank god i'm
behind this [ __ ] camera
yeah i got to say i think you guys came
back that day and you guys all bonded
like some real trauma bonding between
you guys oh no
yeah i could not believe that whole day
man like it was like what doesn't come
through on the final edit is that he was
non-stop there was no off switch for him
i was very impressed with his energy
like we've said but he was bouncing
around from person to person all day
right with no off yeah it was it was
just like a lot at once and i was hiding
my face behind the camera the whole time
because i couldn't even
look at people
yeah but um
everyone did a great job the four of us
and i gotta say the reason why it took
so long to
air this final edit is because the first
cut
we cut all his bad jokes
and uh it just made him look pretty
innocent for the most part and then
we included this what you see is what
you get right that was tripping me out
today the bunny it looked like the bunny
was moving its mouth as cam was talking
are you the bunny bunny oh [ __ ]
bunny cam cam talk cam talk
hi everybody it's me the bunny here on
uh off the rails today i'm a talking
bunny thanks for tuning in i'll be back
in our boxes
for like i need like 10 minutes for my
butthole to cool off
there's no way i'm going to be able to
sit down anytime soon
[Music]
yeah the only thing we cut cam was when
he may have committed a crime right
yeah that's gone yeah and like other
like just general
cringe jokes but these this is kind of
like the uh the top of the cringe jokes
all right sorry guys i'm trying my best
here
the outlaws act
we're going over now to talk to the
producers
oh there's security there will they
chase you be careful as a car
yeah you're good
no you're not there's a bus stop stop
there's a bus
all right back it up go go go go go
before this car comes go no the guard's
going stop you didn't wait if you drop
what's up in front of kimmel that could
be a good move right getting close to
kimmel
it's okay
one's outside
do i know you
i don't know i don't think so i met you
20 years ago
in philly
you were having sex with my cousin
and i didn't even know you knew irving
got him his cousin's a god oh wow
hilarious [ __ ] wrecked bro he just
called you gay all right see that coming
that guy's like i was born 20 years ago
what are you talking about yeah
dude you're like three times his age for
sure yeah
bingo bingo
that's it
no oh
just have another three minutes here
guys approximately
i think youtube pulled the plug
hey youtube stop playing try refreshing
it see what time stamp you're at it's at
14 51. all right it's actually google
drive
[Music]
it's not okay
14
here we go bingo bingo bingo
all right let's get them boys
you guys know where the jimmy kimmel
show is
[Music]
that's not a joke right he's actually
looking
so the guy said keep it moving and walk
so can you walk past again do jokes and
keep it moving or you don't do it and
this way you get noticed you're not
going to get noticed across the street
guys
rumor has it we're going to be on jimmy
kimmel right now it's a big rumor let's
go you look good what happened
hi
how are you doing
that's zach he's the celebrity they
don't know why i'm
going on a diet obviously but you got to
remember so if i do a joke and you see
me stop go bingo but do it loudly
jimmy lee the jersey owl we're down here
at the jimmy kimmel show we may be
getting on ted turner's here hold on
holy [ __ ]
teddy come here teddy come say hello we
don't bite come here you stinker how you
been teddy
it's a nice zap but you look like you
just got out how you been good where are
you going i'm good but i know you that
guy
chasing me from here
clash of security guards
so what's happening here
so um
that was kimmel's security guard and i
guess they were shooting something
and we couldn't stand still
and he was like moving along guys right
right so jimmy's like had this idea if
we kept walking back and forth roasting
people then that would suffice and be
okay
but
clearly not
well the best part which which we
explained before but he actually was in
the background of one of the shots right
right so funny he got on oh no
kimberly's on this side now why did um
oh here it is
[Laughter]
you look good did the bus hit you on an
angle
how's this one i was like let me guess
you're going to call her ugly
i know what she had for lunch
a lot okay
nice foot soldier there and now jimmy
lee's acting like that
well they just unsubscribed zach
neil damn ladies and gentlemen we can't
cannot film here without permission
we're with the city he's with the city
it was like security or someone for the
chinese theater oh they're like hell no
yeah
let's see did jimmy acknowledge or
they tried to start doing [ __ ] with the
guy
we're with the city i guess
which city bingo
what happened to you you're like a bank
you lost interest i'm fading you are
we're all getting tired zach when you do
a joke pretend even though it's canned
and you know what hey you know almost
and you mean like like you just thought
of it ask him where he got a shirt that
said come free when he bangs a 13 year
old kid from thailand
asak how he's doing with the comedy did
he wait
yeah you heard that right hey you know
almost and you mean like like you just
thought of it ask him where he got his
shirt doesn't come free when he bangs a
13 year old kid from thailand don't ask
him that
dude there was there was like one joke
he kept having me like try and say and i
just wouldn't do it
dude he was he was sending you to get
killed over there
he just he's relentless nice [ __ ] did
you [ __ ] kids in thailand pretty much
yeah i mean just the next level of
racism like and just uh well we love
that for him don't we folks
well what was the joke do you remember i
do remember i don't want to say it
though come on no no i'm not gonna say
it
if it's that bad i'll tell you all fair
really it's it's bad but it's don't say
it night okay it's that bad okay
hey zach how he's doing with the comedy
how are you doing with the comedy
[ __ ] awful dude this [ __ ] you know
what jimmy i can't i i can't do this
i'm [ __ ] done i appreciate all the
help there you go avida zane
i guess there's only one jersey outlaw
that's true
that'll always be true well there you go
good job guys
you really went out there and
made something happen it's a tough day
it looked like eh
dude i'm still recovering
from that [ __ ]
well is jimmy online he sure is all
right well let's talk to the outlaw
himself all right one moment this is the
uh
he's recently been appeared on shows
such as jimmy kimmel
the h3 podcast he is the
jersey outlaw
dangerously funny street comedian
jimmy jimmy there jimmy
my man what's going on
how you feeling
you got a round of applause when i get
older i get around to menopause
you get them around in metapods
well when i get a little older i'll get
around to menopause you just gave me a
round of applause but when i get older
i'll probably get around to menopause
why would you get menopause if you're a
man
that was the joke
i'm a guy okay but
wait i don't get it
jimmy i notice your your hairline's
looking crispy today
yeah zach asked me to to fix it up so i
flew in um i flew in the guy from la to
fix it up for you i wanted to do that
that's nice thank you zach zach ripped
me up last time i figured he'll have
something to rip me up for today
so jimmy the last time we had i mean you
i assume you've been watching the show
right
yeah yeah so so you know
kind of the comments and reactions to
your genre of
comedy
and i feel like the last time we had you
on we kind of give you some notes like
you know less
less mean maybe like the ones that i
liked in yours was really the um
self-deprecating jokes really resonated
you know
you clearly didn't take any of that
feedback to heart do you think what
you're doing is working or you think
maybe you're good time to adjust or
what's your thoughts uh
well i do want to say something on air
that um i want to talk to you about
the comedy i do is kind of to laugh at
ourselves and have fun um and i i don't
think people know that a lot of them
that don't know me i have a lot of
haters and i'm if they understood it's
it's just comedy to laugh at ourselves
and have fun and enjoy
um can i challenge you a little bit on
that jimmy comedy yes
i mean you walked up to um
a young girl and told her she basically
just called her ugly right
and he said it looks like a bus hit you
i i did say that yeah
so
maybe more
so i know in this time you probably are
right you have to adjust the problem is
as you said earlier in your podcast once
i go it's hard to stop me once i go
right yeah we notice
i go
it's almost like um that's it there's no
filter you know there's no political
correctness or anything i want your fans
to know that
i do this for fun i'm not a really mean
spirited person i'm deep down a good guy
i just want to have fun
get noticed a little bit and do the type
of comedy i grew up on i i don't have a
meme in my body i don't want people to
hate me for it i want them to realize
what i'm doing is to it's like what don
rickles did when i was a kid which he
did install style com the only
difference is he was fake and people
knew ahead of time what he was doing
that's right people went there with the
expectation that he was to rip them
apart
so when you just kind of rub shoulders
with someone on the street and you're
like hey take off the hat what's wrong
with you and then are you being rude and
you go yeah i am get the hell out of
here
right no you're you're correct you're
correct and uh i'm
sometimes not self-aware of what i'm
doing when i when i get on that you get
in the mood
i get in that that character mode
and um when i was watching your podcast
from two weeks ago and reading the
comments i really realized that uh a lot
of people don't like what i do and i
think maybe when i what i do is just to
make fun of each other and fun and not
to be mean-spirited about it but i'm a
good-natured person and maybe they'd
accept me more to understand what i do
isn't isn't to be malicious and mean
it's just the style the comedy and the
character i do right i actually believe
because i
i've spent time with you when you're not
on
and i do i do yeah i do i would say
you're not a malicious person you're a
sweet man right
i want to apologize to the fans out
there if i upset him because it's not my
um intention to do that and i feel bad
because despite how i act in my persona
i am a sensitive person and i do care
about people i own a bunch of dental
offices i have a lot of nice dental
patients i have a nice family you want
to do stick with your patients jimmy
oh certain ones that know me but i'll
i'll be honest with you ethan with the
way things have been now with the the
economy cove and not as much because
people are very
they get up tight so easy you don't want
to risk losing any clients at this time
correct which before you are willing to
lose some clients
you made that comment when we made the
frescoes in your mouth yeah like i'm
willing to lose a few uh
well what's interesting about clients at
a dentist's office is what's good for
you potentially is they can't leave
well they can make it's a captive
audience
yeah yeah yeah but i i just wanted i
wanted to pilot more like a captured
audience
i wanted to apologize to your crew and
to your fans if i upset people because
it's not ever my intention for that to
happen it's just i like to be fun and
going
and and have fun that's really all i do
i'm an older guy just trying to enjoy
things a little bit and be a little
lighthearted
yeah i think the problem is that it
doesn't come off lighthearted i mean
zach do you want to say anything or ian
or cam or
or anyone who was there on that day
uh you have any feedback for jimmy here
i mean jimmy we we know you on like a
personal level and you you really do
have a good heart you really do when it
when you're when you're james
not not jimmy lee james right um but you
know we were just out there to observe
you and
again you know no ill will we just
wanted to
follow you but there were times where it
felt a little harsh it was a little it
was a little too harsh the shock factor
is i think what gets the attention and
yeah you guys buy all jokes
some people like that i feel like this
is turning into an intervention
i didn't want it like that i just wanted
to speak how i felt from my heart and
tell you i felt and i wanted to
apologize to people if i upset them i'll
be okay all right
so
um
are you working on any new material
maybe to me to meet the times like are
you are you writing some kind of maybe
yeah in fact my sweatsuit is armani do
you like it
that says adidas on it right in the
front no it's armani salvation armani
salvation
armani armani that's funny
yeah i mean that's more on
of the self-deprecation again you know
but it says adidas on the front
i know but you know how good my comedy
tv show is doing ethan
oh
good i'm the only guy that knows about
it yeah that's see that that's good i
like when you do those jokes
in fact
the la press gave me two thumbs down
and the hollywood press gave me one
finger up
there you go
i like that
and uh i'll tell you i'm doing so good
in my show i can't even get in to see me
say that one again i'm sorry i'm doing
so good on my tv show i can't even get
in to see me right you can't even get in
to see yourself perform
right because it doesn't exist or what's
like is that a metaphysical joke
no it's sarcastic because it's it's not
doing well i can't even get in to see me
oh because it doesn't exist
kind of shorter there you go okay
interesting could i ask you some
questions we wanted to decode some of
the jokes trick or treat charlie can you
explain that one
just like you're dressing loud and crazy
like you're a halloween person like in a
costume
it's not as deep as you guys were trying
to make it
the dress goofy for halloween i'd call
you trick or treat charlie what is
charlie a reference to
it's just a a thing i came up with i
have no idea
good i think you guys are going to read
the joke's a little too deep but
well generally i mean okay well jerry
seinfeld says when he writes a joke you
know he focuses on every word needs to
be perfect you know that's not your
mantra that's not no problem
and whatever comes out on film comes out
and it and sometimes the jokes don't
make sense but
you know it is what it is oh i wanted to
ask you you were telling a black
gentleman on the tour bus the war is
over which war were you referring to
say one more time there was a black
gentleman on a tour bus and you were
saying hey the war is over you can run
now what which war were you from
that was probably civil war
you can't be making civil war references
also the ref kind of referencing them as
a freed slave is just a lot i think
right now
i think the racial stuff's so so bad now
and i i've done it i think i don't think
that's been good for decades probably i
think that one i don't even think in the
slightest thing you can do it in the
slightest vein but you did it
but i thought i did it yeah you did it
zach asked me to
time out what
wait you know what
i said zach asked me to do it i'm joking
okay
zach did you tell him to make a civil
war joke
i don't even think i could comprehend or
come up with a civil war joke
the war is over
that's pretty wild then you made another
one to my black friend the war's over
everything's good and you said jump
right i could he said i could have been
in the olympics if i was black do you
want to unpack that one
yeah i i it's just an old school joke
when we were kids most of the people in
the olympics that were around us were
black so i said i could have been a
black guy i could have been in the
olympics i didn't want to go in
right but i guess the joke is that
you could never be a black guy because
you're a white guy right then i said i
don't know if i said the punch but i
said the jews don't go in the olympics
we own the stadiums i don't know if i'm
used that punch wait but hold on are you
jewish
yeah
you are
poor jewish
how part
uh 50
on which side
my mom's half my dad's half
both his mom and his dad are half jews
wow
okay
man that's rough
the jews owning the stadium the black
athletes it's very dangerous stereotypic
jokes that were but those are yeah you
gotta drop those out of your routine
buddy
yeah
the good thing is i don't think most
people even understand what you're
saying so it doesn't escalate
right i think the jokes are antiquated
where they're funny to people older like
me they got them in the 80s not not
today i know i'm aware of that too can i
guess your age jimmy
yeah
lead 20 70.
wait come on you got me you got me like
way older
so i told zach i told zach what i was
yeah what how old are you 16.
you told him 50 didn't you
oh originally i said 54. but then he
asked the truth and i told him 60.
will you shut will you send zach a
picture of your license i'm going to
send you my driver's license i said i
asked you to do that but you wouldn't
i feel like i'm going into a club
yeah called prison
well that's that's my next move that's
my next move
stop laughing it's not funny
all right uh what else we also have um
i want
you said something about having a mutual
orgasm
but you said yes state farm
so it's an old joke where i go up to an
older cup i said you have you and your
wife have mutual orgasm and they say no
we have state farm because they think
the mutual orgasms like insurance
okay so we were on the right oh we have
state farm right it's an old style joke
but it's funny again to older people
young people don't understand it maybe
do you consider put putting on a show
maybe at like a retirement home or
hospice care or something well maybe i
should retire and quit
before i get up saying but maybe just
for the oscars the other night
maybe you should quit
yeah well
because will smith uh
you know chris rock insulted his wife he
went up and slapped her so my wife's
like that's going to happen to you maybe
it's time to to walk away she did tell
me that
are you afraid i mean
what do you think that ever happened to
you has anybody
tried to assault you for something you
said no no but people will get upset but
i have a good vibe on people you've got
to remember i have two security guards
these are big something's really really
happening bad
but um i think my comment doesn't work
as well with the new the new way the
world is and especially since cobin uh
my my way before kovic
well then maybe way before kobe yeah
maybe just too old style for people but
that's what i'm saying you need an
audience who gets your jokes so maybe go
to like bingo night or something and do
the opening night for bingo
bingo
or quit yeah there it is work with me
i'm just saying or are you gonna have to
you're gonna have to freshen up your
material
um but what did you think of the chris
rock what did you think of will smith
smith slapping chris rock
so what i thought is because i do that
kind of comedy i don't think you need to
hit someone if they do it and if you get
upset after the shooting door would say
it really wasn't nice but you know i
mean chris rock's a comedian
so just like i try to do comedy
uh maybe not well but i try you got to
give me effort for that and um you know
you have to uh give him credit but he
said the wrong thing to the wrong person
and that's what i'm afraid it's going to
happen to me yeah point on the street
too because
the world's escalating in the wrong
direction
in the wrong direction how do you mean
well for for me
i i i'm going to try to and i was
talking to some people about it try to
write new material that's more current
and pertinent so i could be more funny
to like the boomers and the people your
age i've been thinking about boomers
those are old people i don't know the
people that that are not like people i
mean i'm i'm i'm
what are we millennials but boomers are
like my parents i mean those
millennials i meant millennials yeah
that's my life what generation are you
i i guess i'm a baby boomer from the 60s
right yeah so i guess the millennials
right that's what i mean not the
greatest generation
and the gen z's right
yeah
um
but i i don't know i mean i i i my
honest feedback is maybe
maybe work with a younger writer to kind
of help with
because it seems to be something you
really love
and i don't want to take that
whole charisma down how i do stuff i
think i need maybe younger style jokes
yeah
and i'm not so disliked and hated being
too much insult comedy and too much
antiquated comedy that's what that's
what i think where it's going
oh abe has a good point have you seen
have you considered getting on tick tock
he's big on there oh no i'm pretty good
on tick tock
wait hold the anymore let me look up
your take though
i got the key ethan i got the keemstar
guy i'm getting that video went viral
for the keemstar guy it did
at the jersey outlaw jimmy lee
tick tock and you'll see i put up the
keemstar guy a couple of times watch it
it's got a lot of views no way
yeah okay you got 30 000 followers
jersey's funniest guy dude i'm gonna
follow
i appreciate that yeah but like it's
getting a little hot i'm just gonna say
like
yeah i i think you gotta just maybe
you're so you have a son right is he
interested in maybe writing some more
relevant jokes with you
my youngest son kind of is helping me
along with this and he gives me good
advice i don't know if he's a writer for
jokes but he he told me dad you gotta if
you do want to do it you got to stop
insulting people so much and do more
current jokes that people understand
your jokes are funny for people your age
not for the younger people right it
seems like you have people around you
telling the right thing
yeah which is what you said
yeah what do you think about the lady
who you said i got my eye on you
so to me
i thought it was hysterical and and
exactly what it was i thought it was
awful and a really effective and the guy
got mad which made me laugh and yeah he
did he said keep your eye off her i said
i got my eye on you because she had the
patch he probably had a cataract
operation
and then there was an ophthalmologist in
there who i did the rectal uptitus joke
to which was funny
so i i was walking through the
restaurant uh ethan and i said to this
guy you jewish he says no he says get
out into jewish delhi so i thought i was
funny but i don't know if anybody else
did what i mean
right there
do you know that's the whole thing
yeah the i joke seemed to hit with a
decent percentage of okay
i mean it was funny it was just oh it
was very uncomfortable but it was funny
actually yeah there's lots of love in
the chat for the i joke jimmy
so maybe what you should do maybe a good
strategy is to go up to like the most
[ __ ] up looking people
you can find and then just just go in on
them right rip them yeah but you had a
you had a very good point you said in
your other podcast where if someone's
ripping me like the podcast kid and i
come back out of it it's funny but to go
up to random people that don't know me
and start hammering them isn't funny
that's the problem
i took that point to heart that you said
that and maybe it's another good point
yeah
well i'll tell you what jimmy
we know you're a good guy i want to give
you a redemption arc so here's what i
want let's write some new material
let's go back on the street
and let's try the tamer jokes this time
the more self-deprecating or less
insulting and let's see how it hits
let's see could you think you're up for
that assignment are you ready to throw
the cards and you're done
no i was planning on coming out in may i
had mentioned his act today and maybe
what i would do is start getting an
arsenal of self-deprecating jokes more
and less offensive jokes and maybe more
jokes for younger audiences and just do
the same thing in the limo with the
guards and and and and they're saying
back the same vibe but with different
material you have any new jokes you've
got a better response
you have any new jokes you want to hit
us with before we say goodbye
well i had so much gas last night i
thought i was being followed by arabs
uh i
don't know
what else what else
that's the joke after the call
conversation we just said
i let a friend 25 000. hold on hold on
don't move on yet
so the joke is that arabs smell like
farts
no gas arrows sell gas
okay there's so much gas
followed by arrows
they sell gas and oil
is that right
it's not doing all the gas stations my
daddy's telling you it's a little rough
it sounds like you're they're saying
they stink no no no i had so much gas
last night i thought i was being far
behind because that's what they they
make their money in gas and oil but
you're saying you're farting you are
farting
so well i use jokes as a pun so here's
another one you can i lent a friend of
mine 20 000 last week for plastic
surgery and now i can't find the son of
a [ __ ]
because he got a face because he changed
his whole appearance
right right that's it that's that's not
an offensive joke no it's not the arab
one i think dropped
they are going trump that didn't hit you
want to keep trying material and we'll
tell you if it pass
the uh the sniff test this is really
good
more airborne
yeah you have any more arab ones for a b
i was like by the way don't yell yeah no
i i'm interested i was laid back in high
school but i have been late since
okay that's fine yeah
it's a good one
when you're when he's the when you're
your own target you know it it i think
it turns people off a little bit less
that arab [ __ ] was [ __ ] killer dude
but don't say that don't say that yeah
don't i used to be indecisive now i'm
not so sure
that's good
i mean i'm doing dry humor but it's it's
not offensive humor it's not really my
character but not exactly like it's not
exactly like biting social commentary
see jimmy i think i think your best joke
is the one about the hooker where you're
like i hired a hooker last night i
dropped my pants she dropped the price
dropped their price yeah i feel like
that's your strongest joke wait why
could you have a big [ __ ] no because
he's no no no i dropped my table because
i think it would be funnier i was
thinking about that if you go to a
prostitute
and you paid her 100 bucks and then when
you drop your pants she should charge
you more because she's disgusted no she
should give her money back that's even
funnier but she like it's funnier if
they if she raises the price right if
she gives you a discount i mean she
wants to have sex with you she raises
the price she's like well i got another
thing zach to tell you i went i went
even to a discount massage paul i found
out it was self-service
that's that's great
that's a good joke
that i like
uh i'm having a rough time ethan yeah i
got good-looking kids and two ugly kids
i don't bring them up nobody wants to
hear about them
what's the joke there
i got two good looking kids and two ugly
kids but i don't bring them up nobody's
interested in the ugly ones
yeah what's the joke
i have two good looking kids eating two
other kids
maybe if i repeat it enough
am i missing something i don't get this
one either jimmy no he has two good
looks i don't either i just made it up
okay interesting
so you got two ugly kids we don't talk
about them though because they're right
i got a fresh one
you got to tell me if you want it of
course
okay my wife's chinese and every
thursday night she's on her knees
see that's a little rough that one's i
don't see that's that's the freshies
that's the fresh one but that's that's
not good we need those okay all right we
gotta work on fresher you know the arab
ones i'm curious no race jimmy do you
have any jew jokes from europe
yeah jewish jokes i have one of the
jewish woman in a restaurant i said is
there anything here you do like
okay i mean i i could see how that would
work
good good to a jewish crowd but
jewish women
when you go to a jewish comedy club
ethan there's a two complaint minimum
funny
and jewish women in a household if
they're smoking their salmon
there's definitely leftovers
i think because you're jewish maybe
these hit harder you know they seem more
sensitive women a jewish woman i'll tell
you how they spell relief ethan
r-o-l-e-x rolex
okay not they don't sound like try to do
more
appropriate not fresh jokes
yeah i don't know if they're funny but
they're different so
all right i'm not disagreeing i'm
enjoying the set though if you want to
keep going i mean this is great
give me your most defensive ones let's
let's let's just no maybe not no i'm not
still i i take my wife to vegas ethan
every year she plays the slots and i
play the [ __ ] we haven't had one fight
yeah i'm curious what jimmy thinks is
offensive so this will be really
interesting because the ones that jimmy
thinks aren't offensive are probably the
worst ones
all right keep going with the offensive
ones here's another one ethan it's a
clean one i dated a girl and i was 25
years old she had very early american
features when i met her she looked a lot
like a buffalo what was that where you
said that you said some kind of
condition
i said i had dated a girl when i was 25
who had very early american features she
looked a lot like a buffalo early
american feature oh that one's very bad
don't yeah drop that one
ethan whatever you know what yeah you
yeah drop that one immediately
ethan when i was 20 years old i had sex
in las vegas for the first time i was
young and i was frightened and i was
alone
right not what
right no i tried to be gentle ethan but
it was hard
and then ethan i finally got a grip on
myself
and then my italian father said jimmy if
you do that too much you're going to go
blind i should pop them over here
right
chronic masturbator
yeah so i mean that's not being too
offensive that's like a little skit i
wrote wow i had layers different levels
yeah that one kept going yeah but that
one wasn't offensive it's just about
masturbating
yeah the indian or the native american
one was very very offensive
you understand why right
because you don't want to do jokes on
ethnicity
[Music]
i think the world just kind of moved
beyond that
wiggles died man yeah he's gone are you
kidding me is he dead
too much masturbating buddy
so
i i got to keep trying ethan and i think
i got to take your advice and i got to
maybe try to change the material and
try to do better and be build up a fan
base and have people like me and be the
guy on the street that's likable not not
so offensive and rude
and there's no harm in hiring uh there's
no shame in hiring joke writers i mean a
lot a ton if not all great comedians
work with joke writers right
they did when i was thinking if zach had
some free time on the weekend he's not
doing too much with you i'd like to hire
him
what do you think zach
well yeah what's the pay
500 a week
jesus you were born in like 19 20.
a week
that's gonna be a part-time job for two
days a week yeah i mean if it's just a
couple hours a week i mean
jimmy he does 10 hour shifts he he's
going to put you to work but i have a
job here you know as this is like
a full
how many hours you need from him
two days he can sit and write all the
jokes then we'll do current ones and
then i'll go i'll memorize them and go
out on how many how many hours a week
are we talking
how many hours zach you want to do well
here's the thing though not a i'm not a
comedian i
oh my comedy is through sound bites i
guess but like i'm not like a stan we
gotta find he's a good good young guy
that can write some good jokes for me in
in the jersey outlaw style better you
need help we could help we could maybe
find someone yeah yeah
ian would be great
let's get in on that and then i'll come
out in may and we'll we'll do a shoot
and we'll do a different style material
that maybe will work better
chad is saying 500 a week is not bad
i think that's good for poor time what
do you think zack yeah
i mean
oh you know what okay i have a
proposition for you
what is it okay i will work for you
and help you write jokes
for a month oh no i'll do it for two
months straight but you gotta buy me a
rolex
holy [ __ ]
then i gotta talk to ethan and it
because they they make more than me
right now my business is a little flat
so i got to talk ethan off the cuff
about that one why i'm a downward dog
you're one in vegas i i was told you
won't know you counting my money now
i was told you had a big hit in las
vegas and playing at holly
so how much you roll out i mean that's a
good deal two months i mean that might
add up to what jimmy's paying
the one he wants is 10 grand so 10
that's a little steep that's a little
steep
yeah we'll talk you guys can negotiate
yeah a rolly is the price jimmy
i i do want to say that i appreciate
number one that you guys continue to to
to give me uh some love and having you
on and i want to also appreci say i
thank you i appreciate your advice and
i'm gonna start to try and uh change to
do things more current maybe maybe be
more likeable and try and do better
that's what i want i want to
set you up for success let's get let's
try to set you up with a joke writer
you know and let's give you another shot
out there with some fresh comedy
and we're gonna maybe we'll change your
name to uh you know jimmy lee
the jersey uh law abiding citizen
not jimmy lee the jersey ass no
no the law-abiding citizen you're no
longer an [ __ ]
not jimmy lee the jersey [ __ ] jimmy
leave the jersey outlaw clean
yeah cleveland version yeah yeah and
then you say dangerously funny it can be
like uh you know
day
pretty dang funny
pretty dangerous yeah right now what am
i even cancelled culture is that what
they call me now jimmy lee canceled
culture
well i think you have to you have to
first exist to be canceled unfortunately
i i couldn't make a comeback because i
never was a husband right
saying
exactly
just a little jimmy lee style humor
there for you
all right people say hey take off the
glasses jimmy you're making a spectacle
[Laughter]
hey what'd you just get hit by a bus
it's going sideways
no on an angle getting the joker did you
get hit by a cab on an angle hey jimmy
where's uh who let you out of the crypt
aren't you the [ __ ] keeper
no but ethan let me tell you what you
can go home your cage has been cleaned
the cage has been cleaned
you can go home your cage has been
cleaned
what kind of animal am i
that was okay
i threw a curveball at you okay jimmy
well then
uh if you're so
rich
if you're so t i don't know jimmy i'm
not right hey jimmy what how many hair
lines you got over there i see why count
one two four
but ethan you know what i'm looking at
you you have something under your chin
oh really oh it's your other chin
hey jimmy okay what's under your chin
oh it's your other chin your flabby
skinned uh old [ __ ] keeper
you're my buddy i hope you're my buddy
anyway yeah of course we're just having
fun
we're just doing we're just doing some
good old times here
hey jimmy
hey jimmy you got your hearing aids in
or what i keep saying i keep talking but
you don't listen i mean you got to turn
up the hearing aids what
hey ethan i got a funny joke for you
okay
that's it
got him
wow
take that show on the road jimmy you'll
be famous for the end of the month
[Applause]
this was fun
but yeah okay so we're going to set you
hey jimmy you ever heard of uh
kim who's this
what wait who is this this is this is
mao
mao dang chow or whatever the [ __ ]
not that
you got the similar hairline you have
you have you ruled any uh
was he chinese or vietnamese chinese
yeah you rule any chinese countries
lately jimmy he's not give me one second
he's not seeing it i don't know who it
is
who isn't hang on we're going to pull it
up for you right dad oh come on you're
comparing me to that guy hey hey jimmy
you rule any chinese countries lately oh
[ __ ] you really hate me take that there
what do you mean it's just you're this
is the jokes you tell on the street
take it down
okay you can't deal with it
it's too offensive it's too offensive
taking it down
you're killing it you're killing me
thank you brother um
i got a friend who's italian he
embarrassed himself at the latest supper
by asking for seconds
hey jimmy were you at the last supper
yes
hey jimmy why is it so dark in there you
like your wife turn off the lights no
but you ought to we tell tell love
there's personalities for sale at
walmart they're 5.99 ouch
i gotta throw a couple in before i go
get the guys get the guys we're having
fun this is fun you know because
this is good because we're all
consenting it's like an insult right
exactly yeah this is you know if you can
find a way to to set it up in such a way
that it's people
that are voluntarily being roasted by
you it's a totally different dynamic
so ian um i just want to say something
to you ian you're doing a wonderful job
for uh ethan when we figure out what job
you actually do we're going to call you
let you know you got a bright future in
not not in the business you're doing
maybe in the lighting business go easy
on him jimmy
he's a wonderful guy
uh as a matter of opinion his uh
to to um cameron i want to tell you
cameron one day you're going to find
yourself you're going to be terribly
disappointed
oh my god
there's not much to say about cameron
he's got a lousy personality but he's a
nice person and he keeps telling himself
that
and um
we didn't is there anybody that you know
ethan who's egyptian
[Music]
oh jeez i guess not where is this going
who said that dan yeah
just a little worried i got my finger on
the sensor button here i guess i'm the
closest thing to egyptian i mean they're
romanian right uh are you ready for
heritage
right
gypsies are from romania right now he
said egyptian oh egyptian yeah yeah
yeah i mean ila is kind of close to
egyptian and so is ab so take your pick
i guess so a b if he's egyptian i would
just say hope you find a parking place
for your camel
um that could work for a lot of
countries now that one uh
i'm arab what else you got
no no
make up with the jews we'll make your
corned beef sandwich stop already
that's actually a good offer i wonder if
anyone's presented that jim jimmy tell
up tell them the big give me why is it
so dark it keeps getting darker what is
happening there
that's a celebrity vibe a look that's
what me and my son set up for the room
celebrity vibe so yeah we had to set it
up like this hey jimmy the dental the
covert really hit your heart you can't
afford the uh pay the power bill
correct
we use the gamers in the office now we
use electric
jimmy tell hey knock
tell them tell a b the been drinking one
the one you kept having me say oh yeah
yes so i said to zach you got to go up
to a guy with a beard a foreigner and
say you look like osama bin drinking
did you like it
like i like exactly that zach did go up
to someone and do it you did zach no i
didn't that didn't happen that didn't
happen towards the end i thought you did
no never did that one
osama bin drinking
oh so have i been drinking
but osama bin laden was also pretty
haggard oh you could say that about
osama bin laden himself
yeah
he could osama bin laden as osama bin
drinkin right then
yeah
you got any saddam hussein jokes
no
i just never did no
i got a surprise
darker now hey jimmy hey jimmy
jimmy hey jimmy where are you saddam
hussein's hole in the ground
i'm i'm in ukraine i'm in the bomb
shelter oh okay no i'm in the dark area
no good wait now he's gone
[Laughter]
we can't even see you
is it i guess you got dark over there or
something hold on
can you put well you don't want does
that matter oh there he is he got in the
light
we got the light
jimmy crawling out of the crypt man
dude this looks like a video osama
without yeah
you doing isis training video over there
jimmy what's going on i gotta tell you
about those isis people their murder
yeah they are that's good
well i think we did i think we had a
great time here what do you think i
thought it was a lot of fun i am
appreciative of you guys i i love you
and i i am going to try to move in the
right direction and become worker i
really mean it
um i'm excited i'm excited we're
we're going to open the red car we're
going to throw out the red carpet for
you
do a full jimmy lee redemption arc
oh i appreciate it you guys are nice and
if we come out may even we would like
you to be on the street with us no
that's not happening jimmy
there was a comment on my video that you
should be on the street with me i won't
embarrass you i'll make fun of myself
i'll uh i'll i think i have to take my
goldfish for a walk that day
uh you'll be busy that day yeah right so
you're going to leave it to zach again
yeah yeah zach's your man
jimmy but no no crew this time it's got
to be us
oh all right just just your crew yeah
okay and then what about the bodyguard
sack yeah yeah but let's have the
bodyguards there like honestly we you
know we
to be honest we thought this shoot was
gonna be a little different because we
we didn't know you were gonna bring your
own your own crew which kind of
got in the way of ours
so in a lot of this if we shoot you want
me to shoot with my guy on one day and
you want one then you don't want it
together yeah no crossover no
no no this is gonna be a one day thing
yeah this is a one day shift yeah yeah i
understand okay very good
i mean
you want to come run the show for a day
me you want to host the podcast
i'll take a day off
it's your call i could be like don
rickles on johnny course and why not
i have to deal with zach as the co-host
i have to do it with zach as a co-host
though that has to be with me
if you pass the test so what i'll be
here what is the ed mcmahon you're going
to be like ed mcmahon
i'll make you a deal jimmy you passed
the test
of the next uh street comedy vid and
i'll let you have your own segment here
on the show
wow that's impressive you're gonna come
sit right here and do your own
your whole whatever you want to talk
about
well you'd have to tell me how to do it
and what to do okay well let's focus on
the test first
so you want me to start getting all new
stuff and come out and we'll shoot with
you guys in may same vibe but just all
different material hey jimmy don't die
before maine or may all right
i can't die before may the day never
come ethan
the day may never come right and my
classic line ethan before i go good to
see you back in men's clothes right will
you take us to breakfast again
that's not a good one by the way just
only if you're buying zach
[ __ ] that but you know what
i knew that was goblin zach wait hold on
the men's clothes one's not good you
should definitely drop that one too
cause it's kind of like homophobic or
something you know
like transphobic
oh i'm gonna concentrate on
self-deprecating ones and one current
jerk that's kind of what you feel work
better yeah no gay jokes i think that's
that's a good rule of thumb
you know what you know what could be
funny is if uh jimmy gets out of line we
could have the the person like cam met
vegas oh
such a funny idea don't give jimmy a
spank
we should have some kind of penalty for
when jimmy
crosses the line
what do you have a big dude that's gonna
punch me or something no she's a she's a
dominatrix
and she'll like give you a spank on the
butt with like a whip
is your wife okay with that
my wife's cool
yeah okay
because i i think that could be a really
cool crossover what do you guys i think
though
fantastic
dan you're speechless
yeah we'll we'll get that rolling
[Laughter]
hey dan can i answer your question
absolutely
have you hated me since you met me or
just recently
uh no i i don't i don't hate you jimmy
it's not like that
like
jimmy you you always ask if we hate you
why why do you think well i know zach
hated me by the end of the shoot i must
have told him well that's i don't hate
you
i mean you're a lot you're a lot to
spend ten hours with to be fair i mean
you know that yeah that's here and i got
to put up with myself every day exactly
that's what i'm saying so you you know
me one day dan how fast that
the real the real person we gotta
interview is your wife um
i mean talk about trauma
how does she live
how does she live on
she's a trooper even my wife yeah she
must be
she understands me
that's good actually see that that's
beautiful actually i like that you guys
are i've been with my wife ethan since
we were kids she's the most loyal honest
good person you'll meet oh yeah that's
so nice
i was in dental school
that's really sweet actually
when we were getting married uh the
judge said i do and my wife said with
who and he pointed to me and my wife was
happily ever after since that
no well for me not her
see that's something
how weird it is my wife now she wants to
have sex with in the back seat of course
she wants me to drive
right
right a cuckold joke yeah
see there it is this is when i think a
whip would that works for me yeah
oh come on that wasn't that bad no i
said i don't know we were saying no
that's good that was a good one
yeah i like that
said it works for me
yeah i'm going to be trying for you
well you know do it you know do it for
yourself if this is something you want
to do
but i think you i think people are
people are i see in the chat people are
um
they're coming to your side a little bit
now that they see you as a human being
right
really yeah they're coming around
they're coming around on the on the
outlaw on the uh
on the uh good the good law-abiding
citizen jimmy lee
so ethe i got a question here this is
just because you you know your your
generation i don't if if i got famous as
a performer who knows if that'll even
happen and people know i do insult style
comedy would that work once they know it
and everybody knows the style or is it
just still still too antiquated to even
do that
if you had a name well if you want to do
comedy
you should probably get in the club
right and and practice like kind of on
trial
i did that three years i did stand up
for years when i did stand up it wasn't
insult comedy was more skits and jokes
well that's that's the way to do it
that's what i was doing but i i diverted
onto the youtube and the
i i picked up more steam and notoriety
doing the street comedy so i stayed with
that and i kind of let the stand up go
because i was getting too old to drive
around at night and come home late they
don't pay you
uh but it wasn't really insult comey it
was more like old school comedy like
allen and fosse and stuff like that
but it was old school i would say that's
probably your best bet you know i mean
the insults are good on yourself
right i hate myself that could be your
punchline i'm jimmy lee i hate myself
and zach agrees
you're a good man jimmy all right
thank you guys very very much i'm very
appreciative be careful out there okay i
don't want you to get it
like i said don't don't die before may
okay
i'm gonna be careful when i appreciate
you being nice i mean it and to all you
guys thank you and once again if i
offended anybody it wasn't intentional
i mean man i i got a good horn i just
like to be noticed and and do fun stuff
that's there it is work with him
work
well that turned out nice that was that
that was great all right jimmy thanks so
much we're going to be in touch we're
going to set this up
and uh
yeah someone said you should get on
cameo
oh boy i just got i just got on cameo
about a week i got my first person right
now
yeah
i made 25
so far okay
so about that rolex jimmy
no doc thank you jack's the one that
told me to do it okay there you go wait
who who the
i want to look at it jimmy jimmy lee
what do you go by what do you go by on
cameo what's your name where's the apple
it's up there jimmy lee i found it
he
all right let's see let's see what your
first cameo let's see what the trailer
is here let's see
okay
i did it last friday night at the hard
rock
wait what's happening
it's like a 10-second thing
are you not finding anything
it's not playing i mean i'm click here
hey it's jimmy lee the jersey apple
store comedy tv show dangerously funny
i'm here to insult you rip you and make
fun of you come on down
hey you could probably
it's good but there's a lot of dead air
at the front and back of that video
okay
so what do you want me to make it even
shorter but it's kind of funny right
it's charming yeah it's fine yeah i
think it's part of it
well this is good you can insult these
people because that's what they're
coming for right right and i think ethan
what's important because i did listen to
you in the one two weeks if if you could
get really known as say like an insult
comic it it would be accepted more like
rickles when they went to see them they
wanted to signal get insulted because
they knew but people don't know so they
get so offended because i'm a random guy
like you said walking up to them right
i'm laughing at the business use for 175
we might be able to put something
together
say it again
i just laughing that the business use is
175. like we should put him in a
commercial or something
all right jimmy well there it is okay uh
take care you know and i look forward to
seeing you again in may i believe
yeah thank you very much i can't keep
everything thanks for coming out with me
couple weeks all right now get back
inside it looks cold out there
thank you buddy all right take care
hope he gets out of the shadow realm
soon
say hi to keemstar were you in the
bathroom with the lights off
dracula dude that was crazy how it just
got darker and darker like what the i
don't know what was going on there but
there you go you guys see it's it's a
it's a whole journey with jimmy
right
you could say that
stop diagnosing him shut the [ __ ] up
jenna just unsubscribe idiot
chew
it's a we're joking
i'm just sorry but if you're in the chat
saying stop diagnosing him what the [ __ ]
how dare you try to be funny on a
comedic podcast it's stupid
god damn
people are saying they like jimmy
king
his wife exiled him enter the shadow
realm
uh
oh jenna was talking to the girl who
said
he had autism oh i'm sorry jenny jenna
that's that's why i don't read chat i
can't get involved with all the antics
jenna i'm so sorry you're 100 right
actually i agree with you you were
talking to jimmy for too long man you're
in too deep hey hey jenny
what a bus hit you
at an angle
i think your bus is hard enough he kept
insisting on that the at an angle thing
yeah
do you know
i don't know why is that worse
i i don't know
let's say an angle he like corrected you
a couple times because a bus hitting is
you know bad right at an angle what's at
the angle me or the bus i'd i'd i don't
like because it's worse to get hit
i don't think so corner of the bus
oh the coroner my guess
you gotta ask him get him back on the
phone
i'm sorry jenna now i feel bad thank you
eva for correcting me love everyone i
chat
you all are troopers
pure
jenna's gone oh no
wait did jenna leave
oh no jenna
we love you jenna she's still in the
shot okay
we love you jenna you're the best that
ever did it
everyone's saying we love you jenna
justice for jenna and i love him
i'm so [ __ ] up how long we've been
going oh boy uh two hours and 18 minutes
should we talk about the goddamn
dubrick so at least we can own the title
yeah i mean i think we should it but
it's
i mean are you still buying
it's where is this it's kind of up to
you
maybe i'm not saying you guys could
continue without me
just take a nap on the table right there
jenna sent a message
she said it's okay i love you guys oh my
god my heart thanks sorry jenna
[Music]
i was just kind of surprised like how do
you survive that whole segment and then
get mad
at an offensive joke but there you go
jenna wasn't
jenna ladies and gentlemen
we love jenna
i'm a right jenna scott name in the sky
i'm gonna hire a plane
we're gonna get it out there
above new york l.a san francisco chicago
not chicago
[ __ ] chicago
you can't disrespect the shy bro
let's talk about dubrick
rick so dubrick's down bad you know he
never did
anything quite this shady until he got
cancelled but
i think he's desperate right for some
cheddar i mean the puzzle thing was i
was about to suggest the puzzle
but everybody said it was so genius like
you had people like
they're like this is such a genius
project by david dobrik so he's always
been a little bit of a schemer but
this is next level right
so here's the video of it promoting it
so i wanted to get my feet a little more
wet with some nfts if you know what i
mean no you don't know or care about
nfts i know that
so i kind of went to the tippy top of
the nft world and check this out i got a
board bunny and not only is a board
bunny but it looks like me look at that
we have the same hat and it's so sick if
you're young at night
it's so sick
i'm sorry guys but this i think his
career is officially over
after saying that naive just like my
brother
and want to get into nfts you should
check out board bunny they have
literally over 150 000 people in the
discord so it's like
a really critical part of that and yep
you need to rewind it you missed a
really important part i did yeah like
the most important part of this whole
video oh [ __ ] uh go right
yeah just go to like there we have the
same hat it's so sick
this is sick you just did it again just
how did i miss it nothing happened okay
but it you pause it at the exact same
part i don't know what do you want me to
do
just watch it without pausing okay here
we go if you're young and naive just
like my brother oh [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
what why did you say that
why did you actually say that
if you're a global loser
if you're a global loser that's still
investing in influencer cryptos
this is perfect for you
brother
and want to get into nfts you should
check out board bunny they have what the
[ __ ] did you say
hey if you're a [ __ ] brain dead loser
who frequently loses loses money to
scams and multi-level marketing schemes
literally over 150 000 people in the
discord so it's like a ginormous ass
group chat um and yeah if you're
interested at all just start on the
instagram page alright let me know so i
wanted to get my feet a little okay
did they let him know did people like
let him know
i don't know dude that's embarrassing
dude
oh yeah
hey do you have that bur uh that uh
herbalife contact he's like if you ever
worked for herbalife
you may love
here's the price activity on openc of
the board bunnies
let's see
5 000 nfts
3.7
thousand
owners
so
zero
six how much is that that's the floor
price
oh it's having a little resurgence here
at the end
yeah i suppose a little bit
but like most of these
just kind of uh
bottoms out pretty much instantly people
are buying this [ __ ] still dude
who though 300 bucks man what the [ __ ]
so sick i'm just blown away that people
are buying this i just it truly blows my
[ __ ] mind like i just
i
mean just can't fathom it that there's
people dropping hundreds of even
hundreds
i just
i'm totally blaffled by this
it's like investing in bertie madoff
after the whole economy collapsed right
like i still believe in you
because it doesn't make any sense i'm
writing him a letter in jail
take my money bernie with the checking
closed
golly man
okay
we have david dobrik's board bunny on on
the blockchain what do we got here
consected sick bruh
duh
this is the serial killer bunny that
kills all of his friends
looks just like him
um did he sell it
wait he sold it
it was sold for one
it sold for eight
sold for one and it sold for 1.5 did he
sell it
that crypto [ __ ] i guess he must have
loved that would that mean are we sure
that's the same
yeah it says david dobrik board nft i
mean i think
yeah and then it's definitely sold he
sold it and what a [ __ ] dumbass
but then which one is his because it
says hype zone
over
by a lot
top one's probably him oh i see
so he didn't okay interesting skate nuts
is him
you think skate nuts is him
yeah
all right we're named
david phase blanks now this is where it
gets interesting a clash of uh titans
here
faceblinks heard about it and revealed
he also received an insane offer for
around 500 to 750 000 to promote it
which he
declined blanks
wow rare dub for blanks i guess
there's been a development there's been
a development though
oh no
on david i'm sorry on facebank's
instagram story he's on views david
dobrik's podcast one hour ago oh my god
my seed is all over this place so it's
before you give him too much credit wow
that sounds what a spineless [ __ ] well
let's see if he confronts him or if it
just turns into a puff piece that's
that's true i guess it's possible i mean
david's gonna cut out anything that
looks bad it's his video right it's not
live that's a good point
hey bro it's good to see you you know
this [ __ ] happens to all of us dude i
just think we should be homies she's
[ __ ] stupid
welcome david dobrik to a long list of
influencers
promoting scams
nice
i mean faze is like i didn't do this
once i'm gonna call you out for it
i mean faze has like been proven to be
working with a lot of these crypto
schemes right love
face yes bank smell yep he owns phase
yeah
yeah i mean he's
i don't deal with this [ __ ] and then
meanwhile my company is like buying and
selling let me rephrase it
other face members individual members of
phase because i thought there was
something where phase clan the
organization was never okay so that's
different about it
no i think uh
dude half a million
stayed relatively clean
by the way okay so apologies to banks
[ __ ] fraudulent
dude he says they offered him half a
million for a story
that's insane and shows the messages too
i can get you 500k now paid before just
for a follow and a story post yo that
should just tell you how
um
lucrative these are
did five would you give for a story
only one story 15 seconds that's it
happening right now call me
i know you have a ton of deals going
left to right
but to get paid 500 to 750 before you
have to do anything it's just for a
follow and 10 seconds bro
yeah that's shady
that's like basically just someone
handing you like a bag of cash like
unmarked no trace
they're like yo just take this bag of
cash and just give a shout out to like
uh
uh
this company real fast like i'm sorry
who does that that's so shady
it's obviously something shady when
that's the conditions
like oh what is this annoying bro wait
hold on face clan moon pay what is this
i don't know i'm not sure what is that
kim
to the moon pay
whatever i don't care anyone doing this
[ __ ] is lame
um
in a recent post who's this guy zack xbt
called out youtube star david doba
promoting alleged six million dollar nft
scam
oh that's when we read ford bunny has
addressed concerns of their nfts in the
past on february 18 they assured holders
the floor place wasn't being manipulated
and urged them to list nfts at higher
prices guys stop selling it so low
that's how the free market works by the
way yeah
guys stop selling your nfts for so long
you're ruining our [ __ ]
wow
they also revealed that they've been
legally pursuing the removal of
defamatory statements and blatant lies
yeah right and them and their nfts on
the internet however they've remained
silent on social media ever since which
actually
that was the case when i wrote it up
yesterday um but they
tweeted
uh yesterday afternoon apparently for
the first time in over a month
i'm just looking at it now
and um
you know they're giving some uh excuses
for why they had disappeared for so long
but the replies are just full of people
guys i'm banned from the discord as
possible change that most of the big
holders are oh my god uh
they disappeared no communication no
progress at all david dobrik sitting on
half a million bucks like hey guys if
you're young and gullible like my
brother you're gonna love this project
saw people getting charged for rug
pulling so coming out of hiding this
needs to be reported to the fbi oh true
yeah
i got bought a board bunny and got
rugged so yeah this is well of course
you got rugged bro
you bought something called a board
bunny
this is what david was
very excited to
sell to um his young naive fans in his
own world just like my brother here
if you're young and naive
david has not addressed this so of
course this happened a couple of months
ago i guess and then blanks just called
him out for it right yeah it happened i
think in january is when it was
announced and just recently faced well
let's take a vote you guys think that
that blanks is going to call david out
or they're just going to like be friends
and nothing matters no he called him out
and how do you know already i
he's talked about on his story and he
said that they would come to a
resolution they did something he teased
it
interesting all right blanks let's see
it what the [ __ ] are you saying
i'm saying i want to see the podcast of
you on dubrick
do brick but like you said i mean
david does have he's like yo i got a
real problem with this crypto [ __ ] but
the excavator and the essay and all that
[ __ ] i'm cool with that doug had sex in
the tree house
i'm actually cool with all that stuff
just don't [ __ ] with my money okay
did he call him out on that stuff you
know what i'm saying like
you know
doubtful
all right that's enough for me i'm gonna
go die
i'm gonna die before jimmy does
all right
all right that turned out more wholesome
you know i'm happy i was afraid
i'm happy with the way it went it could
have it could have been worse because
yeah worse definitely he's already
blowing up my phone
we're still live jimmy
rita i really appreciate you guys having
me on just that kind of message when you
can please send me download the two
videos when you can really appreciate
you guys wait he wants you to download
the episode and send it to him he won't
always ask for that well he also wants
the
thing we made and then he also wants his
portion of the show
okay jimmy
we do a full service here for jimmy get
right on that
[Laughter]
did we ever actually send it to him yeah
like i think we do cam can you can you
help me out with that cam please i'm
surprised you guys actually sent that to
him to be honest can you email me the
i mean if you're cool with that ethan i
mean we i don't care i mean i don't care
he wants all the raw footage it's a
little tedious no no no no no no i mean
the man the man has a son i'm sure he
knows how to do that
stamped link to the video i mean yeah i
i do i really go hand over how's this
man gonna write a useful joke he can't
even download a video from the internet
so he he just
if if i don't get it to him like five
minutes after show ends he's going to
bug me like all [ __ ] nights oh so
he's persuaded and also like
god love jimmy i don't know what it is
but
he'll repeat the same [ __ ] thing 20
times
like
i'll tell him like hey jimmy we're gonna
have you on at three today okay cool so
you're gonna have me on at three today
right
like it's i don't know what it is
he just wants to make it happen he's a
goal-oriented individual
all right jimmy we'll get you the tape
but
i think i think we got like big
companies usually charge for that kind
of fee like
you know during my lawsuits they charge
crazy let's invoice him he could hire
cam on the weekend as well
get a rollie out i'm just saying i want
to get zakaroli because i know he's
pretty loaded a tank he's got a roll
dude
he drives a rolls rolls-royce
i'm just saying he's asking a lot of you
he [ __ ] is like all day every day
we got to work on that role on getting
you that rolex
[Laughter]
all right guys that's it that's the show
hope you had fun it was a wild one eh
off the rails
that's what we do good job to the crew
for going out there and capturing that
yeah great job
for the cameron who put that role headed
together which was not easy right
cameron i mean it was five hours of
footage he sifted through so yeah
i lived with the jokes on repeat for
you know a couple weeks and came in on
the weekend to get it done oh [ __ ] i
forgot
i'm glad i'm glad it all came together
as best he could again it's not easy
good job cam really really and he really
saved the edit by by constantly going up
the stack and you know trying to
get some q a done in between and trying
to make it something sensible instead of
just us trying to keep up with jimmy
it's very sweet everyone's a superstar
yeah you guys did a great job ian the
producer with the invisible hand i want
to give a shout out to abey's boxing
match but i mean
we could talk about it on friday right i
mean it's not happening yeah we'll talk
about on friday
closer to the top
put a little respect on it
who's gonna die first you or jimmy
stay tuned watch friday
[Laughter]
all right guys
thank you so much we'll see you on
friday all right take care i'm gonna go
die and i have to go [ __ ] right now
[Music]
[Music]
you